So, da bin ich.
Die Musik ist ein bisschen laut.
Hier mal kurz leise und hier ein bisschen hoch.
Stimmt nämlich die Emote-Lautstärke nicht und die Video-Lautstärke später nicht.
Und Windows-Sound-Setting, Keg-Weight.
So, so ist gut.
Jetzt warten wir mal, bis Twitch gecheckt hat.
Und auch der Stream richtig on ist.
So, jetzt trinke ich mal ein bisschen Tee.
Weil ich war heute schon mal eine Runde Rennen.
Ein bisschen trinken danach ist nie verkehrt.
Ich muss auch erstmal mal ein bisschen wieder erholen.
Diesmal nur um knapp die Hälfte von letztes Wochenende gerannt.
Also nur 5,56 Kilometer anstatt 10,3.
Aber dafür schneller.
Das reicht mir heute auch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was so 20, 30 Sekunden pro Minute schneller ausmacht.
Das ist von easy gar kein Problem.
Renne ich 10 Kilometer durch zu.
Ja, also nach 5 bis 6 reicht es mir jetzt aber auch.
Einfache Katzen-Website programmieren für Anfänger.
What the...
Moment, ich wollte doch das Video gucken.
Der Auer.
Das eine wollte ich mir noch angucken hier.
Wäre extra...
Ne, das da.
Wir bauen den ultimativen Katzen-PC.
Keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich absolut wieder sinnlos.
Sinnlos Bild, weil es geht.
Aber mal reingucken wollte ich.
How rich people buy watches.
Das wollte ich schon immer mal wissen.
Best Code Editor Tierlist.
Okay, okay.
Chat, gell.
Also es gibt ein paar Leute auf YouTube, die garantiert ausflippen werden.
Wenn da nicht Wim oben steht.
Oder NeoWim.
Für mich ist Wim nicht mehr oben.
Und auch nicht Emax.
Moin Max.
Anstrengend? Ja, habe ich schon.
Also ich sage euch mal ehrlich.
Der Best Code Editor, wenn man das mal ausweitet.
So auf ein bisschen links und ein bisschen rechts.
Wenn man mal nicht wirklich ganz stumpf bei Editor bleibt.
Weil, ganz ehrlich.
Visual Studio Code.
Gerade mit dem, wie das die meisten Leute aufgemotzt haben.
Kann weitaus mehr.
Als ein simpler Code Editor.
Also.
Schließen wir mal die JetBrains Ideen beispielsweise mit ein.
Ich würde sagen, der beste Code Editor.
Hängt ganz stark natürlich davon ab, was man machen will.
So universal würde ich sagen.
Visual Studio Code tatsächlich.
Auch wenn ich ein Elektron-Hasser bin.
Aber Visual Studio Code ist wirklich nice.
Visual Studio Code ist tatsächlich bei mir auf der 1.
Weil das mit Abstand das vielfältigste dank Plugins ist, was ich kenne.
Du kannst zwar theoretisch.
Wenn du es übertreibst.
Und ihr wisst, ich habe früher auch ein komplett zur IDE aufgemotzten Wim verwendet.
Du kannst natürlich Wim auch übertrieben aufmotzen.
Aber du hast ein paar Sachen, die sind in Visual Studio Code schon schöner.
Was wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich daran liegt, dass die Plugins in Javascript sind.
Und mehr Leute kompetent Javascript können.
Anstatt Wim-Skript oder irgendwelche Lua-Mischmaschdinger von NeoWim.
Gerade so Sachen, dass man mal sieht, wie vielfältig das ist.
Gerade so Sachen wie Plattform-IO für Microcontroller.
Der eingebaute Javascript-Support.
Dann kannst du relativ gut Python drin machen.
Go drin machen.
Du kannst theoretisch, wenn du willst, sogar .NET drin machen.
Wobei ich sagen muss, .NET ist nicht so schön in Visual Studio Code.
Wobei es da erst vor einem Monat oder zwei ein neues Plugin von Microsoft gab.
Was jetzt angeblich viel besser sein soll.
Also ich würde sagen, bei mir ist der Goat eine Mischung aus VS Code.
Für das, wo Visual Studio Code seine Stärken hat.
Plus für die jeweilige Sprache eine JetBrains-IDE.
Sei es jetzt Rider oder Goland.
So, das ist so, wie es bei mir aussieht.
Gucken wir mal.
Eigentlich sind wir noch gar nicht beim Videokurs.
Aber trotzdem.
Schauen wir mal, was er dazu sagt.
By the way, Leute.
Wie mache ich die Lautstärke nochmal lauter von Shorts?
Ich checke es immer nicht.
Ich habe das, glaube ich, sogar noch irgendwo auf.
Das da.
Star Citizen.
Was?
Ach hier.
Ne, ne.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit das interessant ist für die meisten Leute.
Das haben auch ein paar Leute geschickt.
Lass uns mal gucken.
Guck mal hier.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Aber schick nochmal.
Schick nochmal.
Vielleicht ist mir es nachher danach.
So, also lass uns mal kurz gucken.
Also, wie macht man Shorts nochmal lauter?
Alter, das ist so hässlich, YouTube, Mann.
Dieses Pop-Up.
Lul, Alter.
Ist das hässlich.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man Shorts lauter macht.
So geil, Alter.
Macht man Shorts lauter, indem man Videos lauter macht und dann Shorts reloadet?
Ne.
Okay, ich habe, ich habe seriously absolut keine Ahnung.
Okay, YouTube Shorts Volume.
Es geht nicht, oder?
Kann das sein, dass man Shorts...
Alter, YouTube, Mann.
Das ist so ein Ding, was mir echt auf den Sack geht.
Die Vertabletifizierung von Desktop-Anwendungen.
Ja, mit dem Volume Master kann ich das machen.
Aber das ist doch, das ist doch Kacke.
Guck mal hier.
Also hier habe ich es laut, hier nicht.
Ja, aber das ist doch, das ist doch mal richtig, richtig hängen geblieben, Mann.
Vielleicht, vielleicht, wenn man das inkognito aufmacht.
Jetzt ist es besser.
Guck hier.
Was?
Das wollte ich gar nicht.
Wollte...
Copy Link.
Wow, schrei nicht so rum, Mann.
Plus, Minus?
Ja, schauen wir mal.
Guck mal, warte mal.
Ne.
Nein, Pfeil hoch, Pfeil runter, schaltet.
Also, ich habe, ich habe legit keine Ahnung, wie man Shorts...
Aber lasst uns mal die Tierliste Editors angucken, schnell.
Jetzt ist es zu laut.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Visual Studio Code auf Create.
Okay, dann hat er garantiert NeoVim auf Goat.
Was sonst?
Ich auch nicht.
Ich verstehe seriously auch nicht mal, wie man Emacs verwendet.
Ich habe das früher mal viel verwendet.
Also, das war so die Zeit, wo ich auch mein Vim übelst aufgebohrt habe und sowas.
Aber ich verstehe es nicht, wie man es aktuell noch benutzt.
Es gibt manche Leute, die schwören immer noch ultra auf Ork-Mode.
Aber selbst dafür, also wenn das das einzige ist, würde ich auch kein Emacs mehr benutzen.
Sublime Text ist nice.
Sublime Text war seiner Zeit richtig voraus.
Es gab mal eine Zeit, so, ich würde mal so sagen, 2010 rum oder sowas.
Da hat jeder, der hip war, Sublime Text verwendet.
Ich glaube aber mittlerweile ist Sublime Text ziemlich in Ungnade gefallen irgendwie.
Wahrscheinlich, weil sie so lange mit Version 3 gebraucht haben.
Und ich glaube immer noch kein gescheites Terminal-Build-in haben und sowas.
Naja, why would you pay, wenn es für einen taugt.
Und man damit am angenehmsten arbeiten kann.
Warum nicht?
Also ich sehe überhaupt kein Problem drin für Software, die man wirklich gerne verwendet.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre Sublime Text super teuer oder so.
Was kostet das, 30 Euro oder so?
Jetzt kommt Notepad++.
Ne, dachte ich mir.
Dachte ich mir eigentlich.
Dachte, dass jetzt nach Notepad Notepad++ kommt.
Wobei die Dinger ja eigentlich überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
Ja, also Notepad ist wirklich F-Tier.
Wisst ihr, was das wirklich einzig Gute an Notepad ist?
Wofür ich das auch manchmal verwende.
Das ist, das einzig Gute an Notepad ist, dass es instant startet.
Guck, dass du sagst, bin auf dem Klo zum Beispiel.
Doch, ich gehe jetzt nicht aufs Klo.
Na, und mach das dann groß.
Also dafür ist Notepad ganz gut.
Für den Rest kannst du Notepad komplett vergessen, man.
Ja, Atom würde ich theoretisch auch.
Hätte ich früher auf die gleiche Stufe gesetzt für Visual Studio Code.
Atom ist ja quasi der Ur-Ur-Urgroßvater von allem Elektron lastigem.
Damals, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das wisst,
aber Elektron kommt aus dem Atom Editor Projekt.
Und ursprünglich hieß das nämlich auch nicht Elektron,
sondern Atom Shell, der Elektron-Vorgänger.
Also kann man auch so, kann man auch...
Atom Shell?
Ja, guck.
Achso, ja, ja, Elektron.
Das ist was anderes.
Und jetzt heißt es halt...
Jetzt weiß ich auch, Leute, jetzt weiß ich auch,
warum es Elektron heißt, das Ding.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich den Zusammenhang erkannt habe.
Jetzt weiß ich, warum das JavaScript Elektron heißt.
Der Vorgänger war Atom Shell und jetzt haben sie es Elektron genannt.
Excellent.
Wusstet ihr das?
Also mir war das bis jetzt nicht klar, ja.
Ich glaube, das wussten die meisten nicht.
Aber jetzt, jetzt, jetzt erschließt sich mehr die...
Die Synapsen haben sich verbunden, ja.
Darkseid, danke für den Sub.
Jetzt verstehe ich das, okay.
Also Atom ist das Problem,
das hätte ich früher auf die gleiche Ebene von VS Code gesetzt.
Es ist ja auch quasi so, von dem was...
Also influential, muss man sagen, ist Atom ganz oben.
Atom hat quasi eine komplette neue Generation von Apps gespawnt.
Unbewusst.
Aber da Atom mittlerweile unsupported, unentwickelt und überhaupt ist,
Atom, würde ich sagen, ist das eigentlich vielleicht nicht F-Tier.
Das wurde...
Spätestens mit dem Microsoft-Kauf von GitHub war eigentlich klar,
dass sich das erledigt hat, ja.
Also, ja.
Es gibt einen Atom-Fork,
habe ich schon mitgekriegt, der ihr Pulser...
Aber ich weiß gar nicht,
ob das überhaupt noch weiterentwickelt wird.
Ja, tatsächlich, das wird noch weiterentwickelt, okay.
Ja, zumindest...
Warum sind wir jetzt auf einmal wieder bei Emacs,
weil mich das Ding verarschen?
Ah ja, hier.
Also Atom, würde ich sagen, ist decent, würde ich sagen.
Ich würde eigentlich mittlerweile fast schon auf Y schieben,
weil nicht mehr weiterentwickelt, würde ich nicht verwenden.
Weil nicht mehr weiterentwickelt, würde ich nicht verwenden.
Atom wird nicht mehr weiterentwickelt, allein schon deswegen.
Und dementsprechend auch keine Plugins für irgendwas.
Im Leben nicht, ne.
Ja, also das finde ich jetzt unsinnig.
Das finde ich unsinnig.
Ja, Atom ist historisch gesehen eines der, sagen wir mal,
mit eines der wichtigsten so Dinger der letzten Jahre gewesen.
Gerade, weil es Elektron gespawnt hat.
Aber ich werde garantiert jetzt keinen Anfang 2023
und seit Jahren schon nicht mal richtig Support and Editor
auf S-Tier voten.
Das macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Tobi, ich verstehe Fleet auch nicht, den Sinn davon.
Also ich gette, dass JetBrains so ein bisschen was haben möchte
wie VS Code, aber ich sehe es aktuell noch weniger.
Ich weiß schon, einer macht direkt ein Reaction-Video da drauf jetzt.
Notepad++ ist decent.
Decent ist Notepad++.
Ja, da bedanke ich mich.
Okay, Leute, da stimme ich.
By the way, und dass man Shorts nicht richtig spulen kann,
fuckt mich auch ultra ab, man.
Konnte man nicht einfach sagen,
hier Watch und dann die Shorts-ID hintendran?
Nee?
Okay, dann weiß ich es auch nicht.
Wie kommt man bei Shorts jetzt auf das richtige,
auf die richtige Video-ID?
Das ist so komplett für den Arsch, das zu benutzen, Mann.
Die Bedienung ist so krass für den Arsch, Alter.
Oh, Mann.
Naja, also zumindest seriously.
Jetzt muss man...
Kann ich mal spulen?
Naja, also ich...
Damit gehe ich nicht...
Damit gehe ich nicht konform mit seiner Tierlist.
Ich weiß, dass man Shorts irgendwie spulen kann,
wenn man auf das eigentliche Video geht.
Ich habe es gerade probiert mit der ID.
Nee, nee, es hat nicht funktioniert.
Ah, Moment. Kann es sein, dass ich einfach nicht alles...
Ich habe nicht alles kopiert, Leute.
Ich glaube, ich habe nicht alles kopiert.
Ich habe es gerade verkehrt gemacht.
Guck mal, ich habe nicht alles kopiert.
Ich hatte nicht alles kopiert, deswegen.
Okay, gut.
Also, guck mal.
Der hat Goat, Atom, Seriously,
ein eingestellter, nicht mehr supporteter Text,
auch wenn er einflussreich war.
Aber nee, trotzdem nicht.
Visual Studio Code und Vim auf Create lasse ich mir gefallen.
Die Frage ist nur, was dann in S-Tier gehen soll,
wenn es nicht Visual Studio Code ist.
Ansonsten, den Rest kann man so lassen.
Denke ich, ist okay.
Notepad gehe ich auch mit.
Wobei ich ganz ehrlich...
Es gibt ja noch deutlich mehr Sachen,
die man da ranken könnte.
Könnte da wahrscheinlich noch 20 weitere Texteditors ranken.
Die ganzen Nano-Enjoyer finden sich hier wahrscheinlich nicht drin.
Wobei ich niemand kenne,
der mit Nano ernsthafte Projekte macht.
Diese ganzen neuen Dinger von GitHub fehlen.
Texteditor, Written in Rust,
Placingly, Ultra, Hyperfast.
Und es gibt ja zig Sachen,
verschiedenste Dinger,
die auch teilweise 10.000 plus Sternchen haben.
Brackets wird leider auch nicht mehr supported.
Brackets war richtig cool am Anfang.
Das ist aber schon seit 2021 archived.
Also Brackets war wirklich mega nice.
Es gab eigentlich ein Ding,
was Brackets gut gemacht hat.
Vermarktet hat Adobe das Ding noch nie gut.
Was das richtig gut gemacht hat,
ist, du konntest live HTML editieren.
Leider haben die noch nicht mal Bilder auf ihrer Seite davon.
Du konntest live HTML und CSS editieren.
Und es hat es dir direkt live im Browser angezeigt.
Also ein bisschen das,
was mehr oder weniger
jedes Frontend-Framework heute bietet,
mit Hot Module Reload Replacement.
Und das Ganze aber schon 2013 oder sowas.
Also das war wirklich seiner Zeit voraus.
Leider hat das Ökosystem und alles nie wirklich Fahrt aufgenommen.
Aber dafür, hier für Live-Vorschau,
da war Brackets wirklich sehr, sehr nice.
Selbst React Native.
Du meinst, wenn React Native schon was macht,
dann heißt es was.
Macht es was.
Wenn React Native schon was macht, dann heißt es was.
Macht denn in Vim heute ernsthaft Projekte?
Oh ja.
Da fällt mir zum Beispiel einer auf YouTube ein,
der sicherlich darauf auch jetzt bald reaktet,
auf diese Code-Editor-Sache,
so wie ich mir das vorstellen kann.
Da gibt es schon so ein paar Leute,
die ernsthafte Sachen in Vim machen.
Ich glaube, wir haben sogar ein paar Modges hier,
die gerne Vim verwenden.
Ich mache Vim täglich.
Und gerne.
Allerdings nur zum Editieren von kleinen Sachen
auf der Command-Line.
Ich gehe zum Beispiel,
wenn ich eh im Terminal bin und sage,
ach guck mal hier,
config.datei.xy öffnen, kurz reingucken.
Und natürlich über ssh.
Dann immer Vim.
Einfach, weil es am schnellsten und am einfachsten ist.
Aber sobald es irgendwas Großartiges gibt, dann nicht.
Ansonsten, ganz ehrlich,
meine Code-Kombi ist,
kann ich euch ja zeigen,
meine Code-Kombi ist VS Code
plus, sagen wir mal, fürs Backend-Rider.
Oder Goland zum Beispiel.
Bei mir sieht das vom Setup dann immer so aus.
Bin ich eigentlich, Chat?
Muss mal eine Frage an euch.
Verwendet einer von euch Linux zum Software-Entwickeln?
Ich weiß, sind noch nicht so viele da.
Stream ist erst angelaufen.
Mal eine Frage.
Wer von euch verwendet,
ich meine nicht unbedingt beruflich,
sondern auch nicht hauptsächlich.
Aber wer entwickelt mal Linux seinen Kram?
Okay, sind ein paar Leute dabei.
Und jetzt mal eine Frage an euch.
Habt ihr irgendeinen Login-Display-Manager?
Oder macht ihr einfach auch StartX wie ich?
Ich bin nämlich, achso, ja gut.
Oder StartWayland oder wie auch immer man das unter Wayland macht.
Ich hab den Eindruck, ich bin der Einzige,
der einen X-Startup-Script verwendet,
anstatt einen Login-Manager.
Ich seh halt auch den Sinn
überhaupt nicht drin von so einem Login-Manager.
Man könnte das StartX sogar automatisch ausführen lassen,
wenn man sich einloggt,
indem man guckt, auf welchem TTY man ist
und dann ansonsten Konsole startet
oder halt StartX.
Base Ubuntu, okay.
Also ich bin ja kein echter Einziger, der das so macht.
Aber das ist ja das Schöne an Linux.
Du kannst das individuell machen, wie du willst,
wie es einem am besten gefällt.
Ich mach mal kurz Package-Update, wenn wir schon dabei sind.
BlackHD, dankeschön für den Sub.
Oh, neuer Kernel am Start.
Welchen gibt's denn eigentlich?
Es gibt Kernel-Version.
Habt ihr's gesehen irgendwo?
Ah ja.
6.1.6.8 ein LTS-Kernel gibt's.
Und ein 6.6.1.Arch 1.1.
Boah, das ist ja schon
Highly Alpha, oder?
Oder ist der letztens erst rausgekommen?
Bestimmt nicht Alpha.
Alpha-Kernel pushen die eigentlich nicht.
Hier.
Vor vier Tagen wurde Linux 6.1
announced.
Ja, gut, das ist relativ unspektakulär,
sich diese Subversion,
also nicht Subversion, diese Minor-Versions
anzugucken.
Alter.
Hals.
MonkeS.
Package Update.
Visual Studio Code bin,
wo wir gerade dabei sind.
VS Code Update.
Ja, dann zeige ich euch mal, wie das bei mir aussieht.
Also normalerweise sieht das bei mir so aus.
Je nachdem, ob ich gerade hauptsächlich am Frontend
arbeiten bin oder am Backend arbeiten bin,
kommt ein bisschen drauf an, wo ich meinen Editor habe.
Machen wir jetzt mal das hier auf.
Denkt euch einfach mal, das hier wäre
JavaScript Frontend-Zeug.
Dann hätte ich hier Visual Studio Code auf.
Eventuell zusätzlich
ein Terminal noch hier.
Oder hier, je nachdem.
Oder eben einfach nur Terminal hier.
Kommt ein bisschen drauf an,
wie oft ich gerade bei dem,
was ich mache, noch das Terminal brauche.
Aber sagen wir mal, ich habe hier unten vielleicht noch ein Terminal zusätzlich.
Und ja, ich benutze das echte Terminal,
anstatt das VS Code Terminal.
Einfach, weil das ein echtes Terminal ist.
Und in vielen Sachen besser funktioniert.
So, und auf dem vierten Desktop
habe ich dann zum Beispiel Rider auf.
Und mein Backend-Zeug.
Ah, hier so zum Beispiel.
Und da habe ich entweder auch
ein Terminal offen.
Meistens dort auf der
rechten Seite.
Und dass ich mich so ein bisschen an die 100
irgendwie, dass ich nicht total übertreibe mit Zeichenlänge.
Mache ich das tatsächlich ganz gerne.
Also, ich bin niemand, der sagt, ab 80
Zeichen oder ab 120 Zeichen musst du
unbedingt umbrechen. Gibt ja Leute, die schwören
da drauf. Aber ich sag mal so, ab
sagen wir mal so,
ab, ja
also ab einer gewissen
Länge ist halt, ist halt doof.
Deswegen habe ich meistens hier, wenn du
überhaupt da das hochkannst.
Aber meistens habe ich es hier gar nicht auf.
Sondern habe .NET Watch irgendwie im Terminal
an. So, und das ist eigentlich mein ganz
normales Setup.
Oh, meistens habe ich hier gar kein Terminal
auf. Das ist eigentlich mein ganz normales Setup.
Und ganz ehrlich,
das finde ich,
das klappt für mich einfach
am besten. Und je nachdem,
wo ich hauptsächlich dran arbeite, ist
auf 3 und der Rest ist auf 4. Also mal angenommen,
ich mache jetzt hauptsächlich Backend-Sachen.
Dann
geht das auf 3.
Und das geht auf 4.
So. Aber meistens
ist das ja
nicht mehrfach am Tag, wo das geswitched wird.
Sondern ändert sich
dann irgendwann einmal am Tag.
Arbeitest du mit einem Monitor
in der Form? Ja. Wie soll ich denn sonst
was sehen? Du meinst
meinen zweiten Monitor? Ne.
Das ist mein Hauptmonitor.
Deswegen seht ihr das ja auch, wenn ich zwischen Windows
und Linux hier umschalte.
Ja. Also das ist
ehrlich gesagt so das Setup, wie ich das
immer verwende, seit
Jahren schon.
Und das funktioniert für mich wunderbar.
Deswegen ist für mich Goat
eindeutig
VS Code plus
JetBrains IDE.
Wenn man auf mehreren Servern gleichzeitig
arbeitet. Dafür wäre i3 nice.
Aber weißt du was noch nicer ist, um auf mehreren
Servern gleichzeitig zu arbeiten?
TMAX oder einen Terminal mit Tabs
und Splits.
So mache ich das auch immer.
Wieso überhaupt noch Windows?
Für Spiele, für Streaming
und für Videokram.
So. Jetzt haben wir
geupdates. Rebooten wir mal.
Du hast nur einen Monitor. Ne. Ich habe zwei Monitore.
Aber
zwei Rechner.
Zwei Monitore und zwei Rechner.
Hier links neben mir, also
ich habe das mit
in dem Fall ist es MouseWithoutBorders,
weil es von Windows zu Windows geht.
Und nicht Synergy.
Oder sowas. Hier kann ich ja, wenn ich hier an den Rand
gehe, seht ihr ja meine Maus, mein Mauszeiger
verschwindet.
Da switcht er auf den zweiten Monitor rüber.
Wenn ich Control gedrückt halte.
Was so gut ist, naja also mal.
Das Offensichtlichste zuerst.
Wenn du, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich das
überhaupt noch installiert habe.
Wir machen jetzt mal das Offensichtlichste zuerst.
Neben irgendwelchen angenehmen Sachen
machen wir wirklich mal das Offensichtlichste.
Wo T-Max einfach das Beste ist.
Zwei Sachen, zwei Sachen, wo
T-Max das Beste ist.
Habe ich überhaupt noch installiert? Ne.
Brauche ich hier gar nicht mehr, seitdem ich mein neues
Terminal habe. Also.
Stellt euch mal vor, ich bin jetzt Remote
auf dem Server eingeloggt.
Jetzt mache ich T-Max auf.
Und ich starte jetzt hier drin was.
Yes.
Ich habe jetzt hier was, was läuft auf dem Server.
Irgendein Log-Auswertungsskript oder sonst was.
Und jetzt, passt mal auf, was jetzt passiert.
Jetzt crasht
meine Verbindung.
Meine Internetverbindung bricht ab.
Oh Mist.
Was ist denn jetzt mit meinem Programm, was auf dem
Server läuft?
Ja, nix.
Ich habe jetzt hier
was läuft. Ja, nix.
Ich logge mich wieder auf dem Server ein,
attache mich an die T-Max Session und bin wieder auf
der Session, wo mein Programm weiter im Hintergrund läuft.
Also sprich, dass T-Max
erstmal die Programme
und die Sachen, die ich starte und
mache, detached von meiner
SSH-Verbindung. Das ist mit Abstand
das Beste und Wichtigste
da dran.
Normalerweise ist das Problem nämlich,
ja, Screen kann man dafür auch nehmen, aber
dann kommt das Nächste. Du kannst beispielsweise
mehrere Sachen parallel
machen und das finde ich
super nice. Du kannst nämlich
zum Beispiel sagen, ey, hier oben hast du irgendwas
laufen. Hier unten
machst du Auswertung und guckst dir das Ganze
an. Wie? Nicht drauf oder was?
Ungefähr so
sieht es bei mir auch gerade aus.
Ich gucke gerade ab und zu
immer auf den Serverremote
auf der Arbeit drauf.
Da sieht das auch so aus. Hier oben
laufen zwei Sachen und hier unten
läuft dann Auswertung, wenn ich mir das Ganze
angucken kann und I.O.
angucken kann und sowas. Also das ist auch enorm praktisch
und jetzt kommt das aller
Beste, was mit Screen
zwar theoretisch, also das geht mit Screen gar
nicht, was ich euch jetzt gerade gezeigt hab
und jetzt kommt was, was mit Screen auch
nur echt etwas umständlich geht. Ach ja
und das Coole an T-Max ist auch, also neben
diesen Splits kannst du auch mehrere
Tabs offen haben. Das heißt, du musst
dich nicht mehrfach, das ist auch ein riesen
Vorteil gegenüber Screen, du musst
dich nicht, wobei das glaube ich mit Screen um 5 Umwege
auch funktioniert, du musst dich nicht
mehrfach einloggen. Also du
loggst dich einmal auf dem Server ein und willst 5
Sachen gleichzeitig machen.
Machst du dir 5 Tabs auf
und machst die halt. Und wenn
du sagst, hier hast du im Fullscreen
gerade alles laufen, machst du noch
einen Tab auf, guckst kurz nach
und zack machst du den Tab wieder zu.
Das sind alle Sachen, die kannst du
nicht oder nur
kompliziert in Screen machen.
Also mit den Splits gar nicht.
So und jetzt kommt das,
was mit Screen zwar
auch geht, aber auch extrem umständlich.
Ein zweiter Admin
verbindet sich zum gleichen Server
und jetzt
guckt mal, der kann sich
attachen an eure Session.
Das heißt, ihr seht
hier,
Tag Wait,
ich schalte gerade um zwischen
zwei Sessions, seht der Inhalt ist
das gleiche. Also ich
mach das mal beide Terminals.
So guck, wenn ich hier switche, switchst
da drüben auch.
Da kann man mit zwei Leuten,
die sich verbunden haben über SSH auf dem
Server zusammen was machen. Screensharing
quasi. Ohne Screensharing,
nur interaktives Screensharing.
Also das benutze ich beispielsweise gerne
mit Leuten, die auch ein bisschen einen Plan haben, wie man
sich auf Linux Systemen bewegt.
Weil ganz im Ernst,
Teams Screensharing
für Kommandozeilen ist halt doof,
da kann der andere nichts tippen. Und so
lockt sich der andere auch. Also das hier ist
User 1,
das hier ist User 2.
Und da siehst du, jetzt gehe ich
hier hin und mach da ein neues Tab.
Da passt sich meine Teamworkgröße
auch auf den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner
an, dass wir beide das gleiche sehen.
Kann man
Read-Only einstellen? Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Habe ich noch nie den Bedarf dafür gehabt.
Bei Screen muss der explizit erlauben, dass der andere tippen kann.
Aber ich sehe das,
ich sehe die Fall. Also ganz ehrlich,
ich wollte noch nie, ich sage nicht, dass es da keine
Anwendungszwecke für gibt, aber ich wollte noch nie
Read-Only einem anderen Admin
meine Shell-Session sharen.
Ja, das ist aber eklig.
Das kenne ich. Man kann Control
übernehmen, aber dann können auch nicht beide,
da können auch nicht beide richtig
tippen oder mehrere Leute. Hier können sich
drei Leute drauf einloggen, ohne Lag,
ohne Teamscreen-Übertragung. Das ist einfach
viel besser.
Ich glaube, das interessiert Leute auf YouTube nicht.
So, also deswegen
ist T-Max mega nice.
Also eines der Gründe.
Ich persönlich verwende es lokal nicht. Warum?
Naja, weil mein Terminal das alles kann.
Seht ihr hier. Das ist jetzt kein T-Max,
das ist einfach nur mein Terminal, was das macht.
Aber auf dem Server habe ich immer T-Max
und das erste, was ich mache, ist T-Max-Session auf dem Server.
Also ich finde, da ist es eines der
most essential
Dinger, die es gibt. Man kann mit
T-Max natürlich noch zig andere Sachen machen.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid hier auf zwei
verschiedenen Systemen eingeloggt.
Sag ich gleich was zu Chat.
Stellt euch vor, ihr seid hier auf
zwei verschiedenen Systemen eingeloggt.
Da könnt ihr zum Beispiel sagen,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie es funktioniert.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Wie war das?
Set. Synchronize.
Habt ihr gesehen?
Und jetzt tippt der
in beiden Panels
das gleiche. Das heißt,
wenn ich jetzt auf zwei Servern
eingeloggt bin. Ja, hier unten ist
Server 1, oben ist Server 2.
Und ich will bei beiden
Servern sicherstellen, dass ich das gleiche mache.
Ja, zum Beispiel rm
var log keckel.log
dass ich es nicht vergesse.
Dann würde ich das so machen
und könnte das auf beiden Servern ausführen.
Das geht mit
Screen nicht, weil mit Screen hast du
keine
Splits.
Kann Cluster-SSH oder sowas
benutzen dafür, aber
das hier finde ich deutlich angenehmer.
So.
Soviel zu Themux.
Das lohnt sich auf jeden Fall sich anzugucken.
Lokal finde ich es nicht so wichtig.
Genau, kannst Server updaten
zum Beispiel und permanent zugucken
auf beiden. Dann würde ich
zum Beispiel sagen, okay,
man splittet das horizontal,
da kann man sich die Updates
auf dem einen Server angucken, auf dem anderen parallel
und sowas. Das ist wirklich sehr nice.
Also kann ich jedem nur empfehlen, sich das
bisschen anzugucken. Nicht unbedingt lokal.
Lokal, wie gesagt, habe ich mein Terminal
für und weil eben die Frage kam, das Terminal
das hier ist
West Term. Ist nicht so
das allerbekannteste Terminal, aber
trotzdem sehr beliebt.
Written in Rust, natürlich, was sonst?
Placing the fast Terminal
Written in Rust.
Und wer meine Konfig sehen will
dafür,
der kann auf
ChatHub gucken und
Konfig
West Term
Da ist meine Konfig.
Und ihr seht, die Konfig
ist Lua.
Das heißt, ihr könnt komplett
eigene Programme in eurer Terminal
Konfig schreiben.
Was jetzt erstmal echt total dämlich klingt,
aber es hat doch ein paar ganz coole Sachen.
Zum Beispiel, ich zeige euch mal was.
Konfig West Term. Zum Beispiel
das hier. Denkt man sich erstmal
was ist das? Warum brauche ich eine Vorschleife
in meiner
Terminal Konfig? Ja, komplett unsinnig.
Total useless. Aber
so ganz useless ist das Ganze doch nicht.
Und zwar, weil ich hier
Mausklicks
binde. Und zwar Mausklicks
von einem
bis zu 99
kontinuierlichen
Klicks.
By the way, was bedeutet denn in Lua
1,99,1?
Ach, die Steps
sind das, oder? Von 1 bis
99 in 1er Steps.
Vermutlich.
Also 1, 2, 3, also so wie man
zählt halt. So, und guckt,
was das hier macht. Okay, mittlere Maustaste
lassen wir mal außen vor, brauchen wir nicht. Aber
das hier ist eine Funktion, die
hätte ich gerne in jedem anderen Terminal.
Kann ich mir aber nur in Westterm so selbst bauen.
Guckt, und zwar es geht hier um folgendes.
Mal angenommen,
mal angenommen, ich will jetzt das hier
kopieren. Mit der rechten
Maustaste. Dann klicke ich das an,
klicke die rechte Maustaste
und jetzt
klicke ich nochmal rechts
und schon ist es gepasted.
Also ich kann im Endeffekt doppelt
klicken auf das Wort, rechts, rechts
drücken und dann copy, pasted es,
also dann copy und pasted es mir das.
Und das funktioniert nur, das funktioniert
nur dadurch, weil das guckt, okay,
das Event ist
Maus, klick,
klick,
also klick, rechter Mausbutton
1 bis 99
mal in Folge ist egal, weil ich will ja auch,
ups, das war jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen viel,
ich will jetzt ja auch rechtsklick, rechtsklick,
bis zu 99 mal rechtsklick machen können, das soll
immer noch funktionieren. Also es funktioniert folgendermaßen,
der guckt,
achso und ohne irgendwie zusätzliche
Keys. Und das kann
aus meiner Sicht kein anderes Terminal
in der Form bieten.
Also, der guckt,
gibt es eine Selection
in dem aktuell aktiven Fenster?
Also, so, gibt es eine
Selection? Ja, gibt es.
In dem Fall ist vmchamp selected.
Wenn es eine Selection gibt,
dann perform
diese Action und zwar
copy die Selection
in die Primary, also in die
Zwischenablage unter Linux.
Dann kopiere die
Selection in die Zwischenablage,
dann
clear die Selection
und wenn es keine
Selection gibt, dann paste.
Heißt im Endeffekt, ich markiere
das, klicke die rechte
Maustaste, dann wird das in die
Zwischenablage kopiert, die
Selection gecleart
und beim nächsten Mal rechtsklicken
kommt das hier zum
tragen, zack, jetzt hab ich
natürlich das andere. Beim nächsten
Mal klicken, kommt das hier
zum tragen,
dass ich jetzt paste. Mittlere Maustaste
geht übrigens genauso.
Mittlere Maustaste geht genauso.
Irgendwie ist er aber ein bisschen verbackt, guck mal.
Das geht auch, wenn man einfach nur links klickt.
Ja, also man kann es auch
mit der mittleren Maustaste machen, gar kein Ding.
Geht auch.
Hab ich auch hier auch eingestellt,
dass meine mittlere Maustaste
Paste from Primary Selection ist.
Aber ich finde es einfach sehr angenehm,
rechtsklick, rechtsklick machen zu können
und es pastet. Ach stimmt, ja,
ihr habt recht, Linux Copy, Paste das.
Aber so finde ich es halt sehr
nice.
Rechtsklick, rechtsklick, zack, zack.
Pog.
So.
Und sowas kannst du mit Western machen,
weil ich es extrem nice finde. Und du kannst halt auch
sonstige Sachen so, wie du willst
einstellen. Zum Beispiel kannst du
das ein bisschen
TMAX-artig verhält.
Ja, zum Beispiel hier.
Dass man sagt,
was auch immer ich hier gemacht habe,
Ctrl-Up, Ctrl-Down
ist Panels durchschalten
und
5, also ist quasi
Vertical Split, wie bei TMAX
und
Anführungszeichen 2, also ist
Horizontal Split.
Calimero, danke für den Sub.
So, und ansonsten habe ich noch ein bisschen
einen Rand eingestellt.
So.
Background Transparency, ihr seht, ganz wichtig.
Der Hintergrund muss durchscheinen,
sonst sackt das.
Der Müsli-Pepo muss im Hintergrund sein.
Jetzt um 9.52 Uhr.
Ach so.
Wer sich für die Desktop-Hintergründe
interessiert,
die gibt es auch
Open Source auf
GitHub. So.
Dann Fensterrahmen
aus
Das wichtigste Projekt auf GitHub.
Nein, nein, nein, das wichtigste, Leute, nein, nein, nein.
Das wichtigste Projekt auf GitHub
ist immer noch
Anime Girls Holding
Programming
Books.
Warum auch immer.
Warum auch immer es das überhaupt gibt,
ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, man weiß nicht genau, warum es das
gibt, aber das gibt es.
Und ansonsten ist es eigentlich
relativ unspektakulär. Ich kann nahezu
unendlich lang zurückscrollen. Scrollbar
ist ausgeschaltet.
Windowgröße wird angepasst, wenn ich die
Schriftgröße ändere.
Fonteinstellung von Größe.
Reverse Video
Cursor
bin ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, wofür
das gut ist.
Ich glaube dafür,
dass der Cursor, wenn der weiß ist
und
er an der Stelle invertet, dass man
das noch gut erkennt, auch wenn weißer Text
drunter ist.
Das hier ist mein Farbschema.
Das ist ein angepasstes
Tomorrow Night
Theme. Nicht das eingebaute Tomorrow
Night, das gefällt mir nicht. Das ist mein
angepasstes Tomorrow Night.
Und ansonsten
war es das. Mehr gibt es nicht.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Das ist das Terminal. Lange
Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Achja, und auf die Frage hin, was
in TMAX die Taste zum Splitten ist,
kommt auf deinen TMAX Modifier an.
Der normale TMAX Modifier ist
CTRL-B. Das heißt, du drückst
CTRL-B und dann drückst du
SHIFT-2, also Anführungszeichen
auf der deutschen Tastatur.
Das ist ein Horizontalsplit
und ein vertikaler
Split ist CTRL-B und
SHIFT-5, also Prozent.
Man kann das übrigens auch
beliebig nesten, wenn man
will. Und wenn du es umsortieren
willst, zu den
vorhandenen Layouts, dann kannst
du sagen, CTRL-B,
Leerzeichen. Dann
kannst du so ein paar vorhandene
Layouts
durch
switchen. Das ist auch ganz praktisch
ab und zu mal, falls man jetzt wirklich sagt,
hey, guck mal hier, ich brauche
jetzt gerade mal hier so was Horizontales.
Ist ganz nützlich. Und ansonsten
gibt es ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht viel, was man an
TMAX Shortcuts kennen muss.
Eine Sache finde ich jetzt persönlich noch ganz
praktisch. Stellt euch mal
vor. Oh ja, ganz
wichtig, das hier.
Ups, was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Ach ja, in TMAX ist
manche Zeichen
kaputt, weil ich sie nicht richtig eingestellt habe,
weil ich es lokal nicht verwende.
Also mal angenommen, hier unten läuft jetzt das hier.
Ach guck mal, in TMAX geht ja auch gar kein
ImageCAD. Also mal angenommen, hier unten
läuft irgendwas. While True,
Echo 1, Sleep 1,
Done. So. Beste.
Das.
Ey, ah, du. Mal angenommen, das hier
unten läuft. Und jetzt stellt euch mal vor,
dieses Command, was hier unten läuft,
wir machen das jetzt mal so, ja.
Dieses Command, was hier unten läuft, macht lange
Zeilenausgabe.
Dann könnt ihr das hier unten jetzt in diesem Split
irgendwie ein bisschen schlecht sehen.
Dann
drückt ihr, dann drückt ihr CTRL B
CTRL Z für Zoom
und dann zoomt er rein. Ihr seht es hier unten übrigens
auch in der Leiste.
Dann zoomt er in dieses eine Panel,
zoomt er rein
und hat das im Fullscreen.
Und wenn ihr dann fertig gucken seid,
dann macht ihr wieder CTRL Z
und dann zoomt das wieder raus.
Das ist übrigens auch sehr praktisch,
wenn ihr das hier copy-pasten müsst.
Also zum Beispiel, ihr wollt diese Zeile
copy-pasten, dann werdet ihr feststellen,
das funktioniert nicht,
weil T-Max ja auf
Terminal-Ebene arbeitet und nix von
irgendwelcher Maus-Selection und so versteht.
Dann geht das nicht, aber ihr könnt das
einfach ran-zoomen und dann könnt ihr ohne Probleme
die Zeile hier kopieren
oder auch mehrere Zeilen kopieren.
Das ist kein Problem.
Mehrere Zeilen kopieren hier würde beispielsweise
nicht funktionieren, weil dann auch diesen Mist
mit kopiert.
Das ist übrigens der Grund, warum ich lokal
mittlerweile auch kein T-Max mehr verwende,
sondern die eingebauten Sachen in meinem Terminal.
Weil mein Terminal
versteht selbstverständlich,
wo Stopp ist und wo
Anfang ist von so einem Panel.
Also das Terminal versteht es nicht,
weil das ist halt einfach nur Text.
Aber auf dem Server ist das trotzdem sehr praktisch.
Also merkt euch, könnt ihr euch noch merken, CTRL B Z
zum ran-zoomen und
CTRL B Pfeiltaste
zum Wechseln von Panels.
Ja, aber die eingebaute
Selection finde ich so abartig
zu benutzen. Also man kann
zum Beispiel, ich kann es euch
zeigen, falls wirklich Leute gibt,
die das benutzen wollen, wenn ich überhaupt noch
zusammenkriege, wie es funktioniert.
Also das sind eigentlich die Sachen, die man merken muss.
Horizontal Split,
Vertical Split, Zoomen,
Pfeiltaste hoch, runter
durch die Panels
und eine Sache, die auch nicht verkehrt ist,
Scrollen.
Weil Scrollen, werdet ihr sehen,
Scrollen funktioniert in T-Max
nicht ohne weiteres
mit dem Mausrad, beziehungsweise hier
mit der Scroll-Leiste vom Terminal,
sondern ihr müsst erst sagen, dass ihr scrollen wollt
und das ist CTRL B
Bild hoch, Bild runter.
Dann könnt ihr scrollen, dann habt ihr so einen eigenen
Scrollback-Buffer in T-Max.
Das ist ganz cool. Also manchmal ist es
nervig, manchmal ist es cool. Hier drinnen könnt ihr jetzt übrigens
auch wieder mit der Maus scrollen.
Wenn ihr den Scroll-Modus
aktiviert habt. Das ist ganz cool,
weil man kann zum Beispiel hier drinnen suchen.
Ich glaube, ich kann jetzt zum Beispiel
sagen, Rider. So und hier kann man
jetzt, guck, kann man quasi seine
seine History, ihr seht es hier oben,
fünf verschiedene Runde von
Rider. Das ist zwar immer die gleiche Ausgabe,
aber es sind fünf Results.
Könnt ihr beispielsweise eure History durchsuchen
von eurer Terminal-Session.
Ja, das ist, das ist
ganz nice.
Und man kann dann die Dinger hier drinnen auch irgendwie
selekten und kopieren,
aber das ist, das ist, oh,
das kann ich nicht ab. Das mag
ich nicht. Vim mit Punkt Terminal?
Ja, du meinst
Neo-Vim mit Punkt Terminal.
Oder hat, oder hat
der, der Original-Vim mittlerweile auch
ein gescheites Terminal drin? Also kann man
machen, aber ich find's, ich
find's, ich, aber selbst mit VI-Modus
ist es kacke. Selection mit Maus
ist in dem Fall das Beste oftmals,
wenn man da irgendwelche
wilden Dinger macht. Einfach anklicken,
rechtsklicken, pack, kopiert.
Ja.
So, so, das jetzt, das jetzt mal
T-Max im Schnelldurchgang.
Wieder was gelernt heute, Chatge.
Ja, das stimmt. Deswegen hab ich's auch
ein bisschen um, ja, also,
wer, wer ein bisschen, wer ein bisschen
angenehmere,
wer ein bisschen angenehmere T-Max-Settings
haben will, der
kann mal in meine
alte, aber ich hab sie ja nicht mehr,
Repos,
in meine alten
.files
gucken. Da gab es auch die T-Max-Konf
dafür. Wobei
das wirklich sehr rudimentär ist und die
wahrscheinlich auch nicht funktioniert. Zumindest hab ich ein paar
Sachen umgelegt. Ich hab zum Beispiel umgelegt,
dass
Eiltaste,
also
Ctrl, Pfeiltaste hoch und runter, direkt die
Panels switcht, Ctrl-F
reinzoomt und
der Copy Mode
nicht so viel scrollt auf einmal.
Ja, das war's im Großen und Ganzen. Also
ein paar Sachen hab ich umgestellt, weil
immer Ctrl-B davor drücken ist extrem blöd.
Denn zum Beispiel, wenn
ihr lokal T-Max verwendet
und dann euch
auf den Server
verbindet, so, stellt euch vor,
ich bin jetzt auf dem Server verbunden,
auf dem Server starte ich nochmal T-Max, dann habt
ihr nested T-Max und jetzt
wird's richtig abartig, wenn ihr nested
T-Max habt, weil
stellt euch mal vor, ihr wollt jetzt
ein neues Panel anlegen
auf dem Server. Wenn ihr aber
jetzt Ctrl-B Split drückt,
dann splittet er bei euch
auf dem
auf dem Host und nicht auf dem Server. Das heißt,
ihr müsst Ctrl-BB
Split drücken,
dass ihr im, oder
Ctrl-BPC für neues Tab,
dass ihr im Server
splittet und nicht
bei euch lokal. Also nested
T-Max, dann wird's richtig abartig.
Das ist auch eines der Gründe, warum ich umgestiegen
bin von T-Max lokal
auf Terminal lokal
und T-Max immer auf dem Server.
Bash History ist quasi mein
mein Brain für
Ja, ja, musst du,
musst du. Ja, da kommst du nicht drum rum.
Glücklicherweise haben's die
meisten Kisten.
Naja, gut.
Kleiner Exkurs.
Ja, es gibt zwei Skripts zum
automatisch umschalten, aber das funktioniert
nur unter speziellen Voraussetzungen.
Vielleicht musst du selbst irgendwas bauen.
Kalimero, danke für den Sub. Und Dan2Dev
Hyper-Subscriptions hier, Leute.
Extrem nice.
Wie genau läuft das mit Zugriffsharen?
Das ist ganz einfach. Du startest T-Max,
jemand anderes lockt sich per SSH ein auf dem
Server mit gleichem Account oder
switched auf den gleichen Account.
Das ist ja am meisten so. Es lockt sich jeder mit
seinem privaten Account,
also User-Account ein,
macht dann sudo-i und
geht auf deine Route T-Max Session.
Also das funktioniert genauso.
Das hier ist User1
und das hier
ist User2. Beide sind
auf dem Server eingeloggt und sind
der gleiche User auf dem Server. Das ist
wichtig. Ansonsten vorher einmal
sudo-i und dann
su-user. Also
ihr müsst auf jeden Fall gleicher User sein auf dem
Server. Irgendeiner lockt sich
zuerst ein, fängt an, dann kommt
der Zweite auf den Server und sagt T-Max A
für Attach und ist auf der gleichen Session
drauf. Guck. Dann schreibe ich
hier rechts und man sieht es und ich schreibe hier links
und man sieht es auch. Ja und man muss
aufpassen, wenn einer die Session
schließt, schließt sich's bei beiden logischerweise.
Ja.
So sieht's aus.
Chat Game.
Was ist das? Ah.
Okay.
Also. Dann lass uns mal gerade gucken, was
auf ShitHub trendet.
Trending. Weekly.
Small Chat
mit C.
Jetzt wollen sie's aber wissen, oder?
Minimal. Naja, für
C-Verhältnis ist es wirklich äußerst
minimal. Ah, Moment. Hier ist noch ne Chat-Libe.
Das geht aber echt.
Das geht aber echt. Klar, ne?
Ah, das ist direktes
Sockets.
Raw-TCP-Verbindung.
Wobei, weiß ich gar nicht. Doch, ja.
Raw-TCP-Verbindung
rübergeschiebe. Das ist, das ist,
das ist gar nicht übel. Also, das ist wirklich
für C-Verhältnis ist das äußerst kurz.
Ja. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie
portable, ob das Linux-only ist
oder nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Gerade das hier mit den
Timestamps sieht mir sehr Linux-mäßig aus.
Timewall.
Select. Ne, Select klingt äußerst
nach Linux-only, gell?
Leute. Ich glaub, das
ist, das ist Linux-only.
Select hört sich sehr
Linux-mäßig an. Ja, gut, halt.
NC. Chat-Server NC mit
Raw-Sockets.
Warum hat das 5,4.000
Sterne?
Das gibt's doch bestimmt schon ewig, oder?
Ne.
Warum hat das so krass viele Sterne,
Alter? Achso.
Der will quasi den IRC
nachbauen. Was auch immer. Aber
scheit, scheit er den
Nerv von GitHub getroffen zu haben.
So, dann gibt es irgendwelche
Machine-Learning-Sachen.
AI, AI, AI.
Juckt alles mich.
Hatten wir das letzte Mal schon.
Proxy.
Elektron Light.
Angular.
Ja, da gab's ne neue Version gestern, ne?
Gab's 17. Oder
vorgestern oder so, ja.
Angular 17
gab's.
Ich sag euch aber, Chat.
Egal wie viele Versionen Angular noch
raushaut, wir gucken es uns nicht an.
Es gibt nämlich, also
Web-Frameworks
ist Angular das, wo ich mit Abstand,
wirklich mit riesen Abstand am wenigsten Bock
da habe, mich damit auseinanderzusetzen.
AI,
AI, AI.
A Log-File-Highlighter.
Das hab ich schon mal irgendwo gesehen.
Blazingly fast written in
Rust.
Gibt's das auch als self-contained binary?
Nö.
Selbst-Selbst-Compile.
AI, AI, AI, AI,
AI, AI, AI,
AI.
Alter, heute ist ja schlimm, ey.
Rust-Zeug.
Äh, was ist das?
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Clash for Windows Chinese.
Was bin ich sehend,
Chat?
Was bin ich sehend?
Was ist das?
Irgendein Proxy oder sowas?
Keine Ahnung.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Können wir mal Translaten lassen.
Warum ist die Bedienung eigentlich so
beschissen geworden hiervon?
Früher konnte man sagen
Detect Language.
Offensichtlich in dem Fall schon.
Warum soll ich jetzt wissen,
was das für eine Sprache ist?
Du konntest sonst einfach sagen, also ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob das Plugin ist, aber ansonsten konntest du einfach sagen
Detect Language und dann macht er das.
Eider.
Klingt ein bisschen österreichisch,
oder? Eider.
Oder schweizerisch
oder so.
AI-Pair-Programming in your terminal.
Na dann.
Sind das die Österreicher oder die
Schweizer, die das immer sagen? Eider.
So.
Jetzt haben wir auch geguckt,
was auf GitHub trendet.
Haben unsere VM aktualisiert.
Aber alles gemacht, was man machen muss.
Chatgill, wisst ihr, was das Schlimme ist?
Ich hab jetzt schon Hunger.
Es ist, ich weiß,
es ist noch zwei Stunden oder so zu früh.
Ich geh jetzt auch nicht
essen, aber ich hab jetzt schon Hunger.
Dauert noch mindestens eine Stunde
fünfzig, bis ich was essen gehen kann.
Na gut. Ich hab heute morgen
wieder 500 Kalorien verbrannt.
Da kann man schon mal Hunger haben.
Geht's gleich zu Maggis.
Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Oh ja.
Was war denn das?
Grimmel, genau.
Ja, ja, das kenn ich.
Grimmel.
Das ist immer noch Grimmel-Linux.
Nee, nicht grill.
Nicht grill, Grimmel.
Debian-Live-System.
Ja, gibt's immer noch.
Grimmel.
Und Grimmel
hieß mit Version 8 mal
irgendwann
Schluchten-Scheißer.
War mal der Codename
für die
Distro.
Die Codenamen sind ja echt
Hardcore-Pipega
Knecht-Rudrecht.
Oh.
Nix.
Mach das. Ich hab noch nix gekauft.
Ich hab aber auch das Geld noch nicht
wieder für das alte.
Ich muss mir mal kurz was drüberziehen,
Sack.
Wusstest du, dass du von Haus aus
bei Rust Unitests machen kannst?
Ja, wusste ich. Aber ihr wisst ja,
immer fehlerfrei programmiert, braucht auch keine
Tests und Doku.
Kurz was drübergezogen.
Also, was haben wir denn heute hier?
Fiat Issues.
Ja, das sind ja auch keine Issues.
Die verstehen's einfach nur nicht.
Fünf hochbezahlte Jobs
ohne Studium.
Äh, wie jetzt? Ohne Abschluss?
Ich glaub, ein Millionär ist
eines der bestbezahlten Jobs
ever.
Ohne Scheiß, jetzt haben wir ein Video
in dieser Richtung hier geguckt
und kriegen jetzt laufend irgendwas empfohlen.
Okay.
Was ist das?
Ups.
Polish Amazon
offers, sorry, sorry,
Amazon, Polish Amazon
offers deals so good
with their servers imploded.
The Polish version of Amazon.
Sieht halt einfach noch mieser aus
als Amazon.
Amazon of Wish.
Okay.
Lass uns mal gucken, was...
Soviel zum Thema Wish, Leute.
Ist Temu nicht auch sowas
Wish-mäßiges? Ich hab
ehrlich keine Ahnung, was Temu eigentlich ist.
Ich hab jetzt ab und zu mal die Werbung
gesehen, aber es sah für mich aus wie
ein weiteres AliExpress
Dropshipping-Ding.
Was ist Temu?
Noch schlimmer?
Äh, wir wollen keine
precise location.
X-Factor, danke für unser...
Temu, okay.
Das sieht ja auch genau aus
wie AliExpress, Mann.
Das sieht aus wie eines
dieser Webseiten vom chinesischen
vom chinesischen
vom chinesischen Webdesign-Ministerium.
Weil die Dinger sind... Guckt euch das mal an.
Die Dinger sehen eh alle gleich aus.
Guck mal hier. AliExpress.
Pass mal auf. AliExpress.
So. Cancel.
Banggood.
Der Name ist eh die geilste...
der geilste Name überhaupt, oder?
Banggood, Alter.
Sieht genauso aus.
Sieht genauso aus. So.
Dann haben wir Temu.
Sieht genauso aus.
Leute, das ist...
Die kommen alle vom chinesischen
Webdesign-Ministerium. Die Dinger
sehen alle gleich aus, Mann.
Sogar die gleiche Scheiß-Schriftblatt hier oben.
So, und wie hieß das andere Ding?
Äh, Store.
Ähm, haben wir auch schon
im Stream geguckt. Ich hab den Namen vergessen.
Die China-Seite, wo ich am wenigsten draufgehe.
Äh, Store. Irgendwas mit Store.
Ah, ich hab's vergessen.
C-Store oder so? Nee.
China-Shops.
Äh, ich hab's vergessen.
Da gibt's...
Die H-Gate gibt's dann, glaube ich, noch.
Auch so ein China-Ding.
Ja.
Das sieht auch so aus. Leute, ohne Scheiß.
Diese ganzen
China-Shop-Webseiten.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Guckt euch das mal an. Diese ganzen China-Shop-Webseiten.
Die sind vom chinesischen
Webdesign-Ministerium.
Die sehen alle gleich aus.
Na, Alibaba ist, ähm,
quasi der AliExpress for Business.
Da bestellst du ja normalerweise
nicht als...
Nicht einzelnes Zeug.
Ob man dort wenig Publisch-Tiere kaufen kann.
Wollen wir mal suchen.
Kann man. Kann man. Gar kein Problem.
Zwar nicht...
Zwar nicht so super viele, ja.
Zwar nicht so super viele.
Und er heißt...
Kann man.
Ich mein, das ist eh nicht original.
Das ist die China-Chinesen-Version davon.
Ja, ist auch so.
Also das Zeug ist wirklich
alles mehr oder weniger das Gleiche.
Das Ding ist halt,
in letzter Zeit lohnt sich das
China-Chinesen-Bestellen gar nicht
mehr so extrem.
Ich hab ja mal vor einer Weile
sehr viel China-Kram bestellt.
Wir haben auch im Stream hier öfters
China-Shopping-Zeug gemacht.
Aber so ungefähr
ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo dieses Schiff
mal quer stand.
Ihr erinnert
euch noch.
Ab da ist es irgendwie kacke geworden.
Vorher auch schon, aber ab da
50 USB-Kabel. Ja,
wir haben auch schon mal 50
USB-Kabel bestellt.
Wir haben auch schon mal 50 USB-Kabel
bestellt. Ja, die hab ich immer noch, 50 USB-Kabel.
USB.
Guck mal, 50
dieses.
Da kriegen wir jetzt bestimmt
USB-Sticks. Ja! Oh, die China!
Das sind die typischen China-
Leute, diesen Stick hatte jeder von euch
schon mal, oder? In irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Diesen Stick.
Ohne Mist, jeder,
oder? Jeder hat diesen Stick schon mal.
Nicht in schwarz unbedingt,
egal welcher Farbe. Jeder
hat den schon mal irgendwo bekommen.
Also exakt diese Art von Stick
jeder. Und die sind so richtig
kacke, diese Sticks.
Die sind so schlimm.
Ich wollte da mal
SSH-Keys drauf speichern.
Und das hat legit
5 Minuten gespeichert.
Für irgendwie 100
Kilobyte, 2 Kilobyte
SSH-Key.
Den hatte wirklich jeder schon mal, diesen Stick.
Auch als
Werbegeschenk und sowas. Und die Dinger sind einfach
nur Schrott.
Und ich hab mal
nen 50er
Pack USB-Kabel bestellt bei
AliExpress. Mein exakt
die, die ich bestellt habe, wird es nicht mehr geben.
Aber
die benutze ich heute noch.
Also ich hatte 50
USB-Kabel bestellt mit USB-C
und Micro-USB
in einem.
Und das war äußerst nice. Die waren billig.
Die haben weniger als ein Euro. Ich glaube, die haben irgendwie
40 Cent oder so
pro Kabel gekostet.
Das war super billig.
Wie 2 Meter Kabel.
Und die verwende ich heute noch regelmäßig.
Und zum größten Teil funktionieren die auch ganz
gut. Also manchmal
ist AliExpress... Ich meine ernsthaft,
guck mal, das ist schon preislich echt
nicht verkehrt. Wenn man hohen Verschleiß
von USB-Kabel hat,
dann kriegt man 19 Euro
für viel.
19 Euro für 5
für 100 Stück.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das ist Blödsinn.
Die Anzahl... Das ist halt
AliExpress. Das ist halt AliExpress
Ding. Größtenteils,
ja. Also ich hatte schon
ein Kabel mal oder ein, zwei Kabel
mal, die ein bisschen Probleme gemacht haben.
Gerade, wenn man Micro-USB auf USB-C
gemacht hat. Aber zum größten Teil funktionieren die gut.
Also es ist schon...
Manchmal lohnt sich das wirklich China-Chinesen-Kram
zu bestellen.
Also wo ich Abstand halten würde
von China-Chinesen-Kram
sind Batterien und
beispielsweise, je nachdem
was es für welche sind,
auch Netzteile.
Also alles was in... Ja gut, das funktioniert
eh nicht hier bei uns. Also alles was
in 230 Volt kommt, würde ich mir das genau
überlegen. Aber USB-Sachen,
Micro-Controller, Sensoren
und Elektronikteile kann man
sich wunderbar kaufen bei AliExpress.
Und von allen den Seiten ist
AliExpress, würde ich sagen, auch... Also ich bin mir
da jetzt... Ich kann euch keine Zahlen sagen.
Aber ich würde sagen, AliExpress ist
davon auch die bekannteste und größte.
Wobei man halt wissen muss, AliExpress verkauft
selber, soweit ich weiß,
gar nichts. AliExpress
ist eigentlich nicht wie Amazon,
sondern AliExpress ist eher wie Amazon Marketplace.
Also ihr seht das auch,
wenn ihr beispielsweise nach ESP32
Bord sucht. Einfach nur als Beispiel.
Es ist egal. Egal was.
Findet gar nicht,
dass es aussieht wie Amazon.
Wie viel bunter und wirrer als Amazon.
Okay, Leute. Wir haben nach dem Falschen gesucht eben.
Wir sind jetzt erstmal
Blacklisted. Zumindest bei Banggood ist es
genauso. Wenn ihr irgendwas anklickt,
ihr werdet sehen, das ist alles...
Ah, das
gute Blitzwolf-Headset.
Ihr werdet sehen, das ist
alles immer... Bei AliExpress
sieht man es besser.
AliExpress hat keinen Bock.
Eigentlich will ich euch nur zeigen,
ja, exakt, das...
Ihr seht immer,
das... Wo ist es denn?
Also normalerweise
sieht man den Händler immer noch. Vielleicht nur,
wenn man eingeloggt ist.
Also das ist kein ESP32.
Warum
sieht man den Händler nicht? Normalerweise
sieht man immer den Händler hier noch. Vielleicht aber, wie gesagt,
echt nur... Also AliExpress ist ein Marketplace.
Ach hier.
Trust4U Store.
Ja,
Wanzai Store.
Ja, hier sieht man es nicht.
Also, das ist
kein Shop wie Amazon,
sondern eigentlich nur ein großer Marketplace.
Das sieht nicht
legit aus, aber das ist legit.
AliExpress kann man super bestellen.
Und mittlerweile kann man auch bei den meisten
Shops, also
bei den meisten Stores bei AliExpress
ganz normal bezahlen
mit
PayPal.
Ja, eigentlich mit PayPal.
Ganz früher,
ich benutze das ja schon wirklich lange,
ganz früher hast du da noch Alipay
gebraucht. Und zu dem
Zeitpunkt, wo ich mir
einen Alipay Account gemacht habe,
zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich mir
einen Alipay Account gemacht habe, da gab es die
Seite nur rein auf Chinesisch.
Und da musstest du dich registrieren. Da gab es so
Guides, wie man sich registriert.
Da gab es Guides, wie man
sich registriert,
weil das niemand gecheckt hat.
Da habe ich mir einen Alipay Account
damals gemacht. Das hast du gebraucht, um dann
irgendwie über PayPal bezahlen zu können.
Also AliExpress ist
wirklich ganz nice, wenn es was
Gutes gibt, was man braucht. In letzter Zeit
ist es ein bisschen unattraktiver geworden, was zu
bestellen. Aber manche Sachen sind
wirklich nice. Zum Beispiel diese
Dinger hier zum Beispiel.
Da muss man mal
gucken. Da kriegt man manchmal
Zehnerpacks für ziemlich
wenig Geld.
Da kriegt man manchmal für ziemlich
wenig Geld. Ja hier guck, zum Beispiel
kriegt man hier
10 Pieces
für 50 Euro.
Das ist
billiger als bei Amazon.
Also 5 Euro
das Stück. Man kriegt es manchmal noch günstiger.
Ich habe es
in einem Zehnerpack gekriegt, da hat es irgendwie
5 Euro gekostet das Stück. Aber die Dinger sind
mega, weil man die mit Custom-Firmware flashen kann.
Und 10 Stück reicht für das ganze
Haus.
Ähm, ich dachte eigentlich,
dass die sich immer noch flashen lassen. Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass die sich zwischenzeitlich nicht haben
flashen lassen.
Man kann die sogar upgraden mit ZigBee.
Die haben sogar einen ZigBee-Sender drin. Hat jetzt
irgendjemand rausgefunden, die Dinger.
Und die benutzt
Xiaomi gar nicht.
Wobei das ist ja... Ich glaube, dass da ZigBee
drin ist, liegt daran, weil ZigBee und
Bluetooth auf 2,4 Gigahertz
sind. Und deswegen
war das für die einfacher.
Also die Dinger sind ganz nice. Die kann man flashen.
Gibt es auf GitHub.
Gibt es hier Custom-Firmware.
Gibt noch mehr Custom-Firmware.
Gibt auch... Also die hier ist gar nicht so
aktiv entwickelt.
Hier habe ich sogar ein bisschen mitgewirkt an der Entwicklung
von dieser Firmware. Indirekt, indirekt.
Ich habe dem
dem Firmaersteller
ein paar Thermometer kostlos zur Verfügung
gestellt zum Basteln.
Natürlich nicht
ganz uneigennützig.
Ich wollte, dass die neue Version unterstützt
wird. Aber
ist doch gut. Hatten alle was davon.
Ihm hier.
Ja. Guck, es gibt da auch
ein paar Forks von.
Guck, hier gibt es sogar schon 3.
Vor 3 Stunden
wurde es geupdated.
Kann man flashen. OTA.
Per Bluetooth. Die Dinger.
Und der riesen
Vorteil davon ist. Also ich kann die Teile
wirklich wärmstens empfehlen.
Gerade, dass ich auch mal so ein 10er Pack
bei AliExpress bestellen.
Ich kann die Dinger wärmstens empfehlen.
In Default Settings
sind die kacke.
Weil in Default Settings
fragen die glaube ich irgendwie alle 5 Sekunden
ihre Sensoren ab.
Und schicken alle
5 oder 10 Sekunden
ihre Sachen per Bluetooth raus.
Das heißt, die sind in einem Jahr
in einem 3 Viertel Jahr sind die Dinger leer.
Da ist ja nur so eine
CR2302
Knopfzelle drin.
So.
Was man mit der Custom Firmware machen kann ist.
Man kann einstellen, dass
beispielsweise nur alle Viertel Stunde
die Sensoren abfragt.
Und alle Viertel Stunde oder alle
20, 30 Minuten oder so
nur die Temperatur schickt
über Bluetooth.
Und das sorgt dafür, dass die Akkulaufzeit
die Batterielaufzeit
einfach mal immens
viel länger ist. Also mein längstes
hat 2,5 Jahre gehalten jetzt.
Das letzte ist leer geworden, was ich im Bad hängen hab.
Ohne Scheiß Leute.
2,5
Jahre
mit einer Knopfzelle
für so ein Ding ist wirklich nice.
Da kannst du dich nicht beschweren.
Also die Kombination.
So ein
Thermostat und Luftfeuchtigkeitssensor
braucht bei sich im Haus
an mehreren Stellen. Beispielsweise wenn ihr
im 1. Stock ein Bad habt und im Erdgeschoss
ein Bad habt oder vielleicht
irgendwie auch mal im Schlafzimmer
gucken wollt und sowas oben und unten.
Dann bietet sich das an.
10 Stück reicht in der Regel fürs ganze Haus.
Die könnt ihr OTA flashen von jedem
PC der Bluetooth eingebaut hat.
Könnt ihr OTA flashen. Also ihr müsst
nix aufschrauben, anlöten oder sowas.
Also OTA heißt quasi Wireless Flashen
mit Custom-Firmware.
Dann stellt ihr das ganze runter auf
15 Minuten wo ihr das verschickt und ihr habt
2 bis 2,5 Jahre
eventuell wenn ihr weiter runter geht 3 Jahre
Batterie-Lebensdauer.
Also das ist eines der besten Home-Automation
Preis-Leistungssachen
die man machen kann. 10er Pack auf AliExpress
kaufen, Custom-Firmware drauf.
Wohin sendet er das? Also neuerdings
kann man ja auch über ZigBee
ja
ja musst du mal suchen hier
ZigBee
guck mal ich glaub sogar
die haben das sogar schon drinnen hier
ja
ist doch in der Firmware schon drinnen mit ZigBee
hier kannst du anscheinend mittlerweile sogar auswählen
ZigBee und
nochmal
also man flasht die
ZigBee-Firmware über BLE und dann sendet
das über ZigBee
wahrscheinlich konfigurieren weiter über BLE
musst du dir hier mal angucken steht bestimmt
das hier irgendwo drauf
ich hab's jetzt nicht im Detail gelesen aber die Firmware hab ich auch
drauf bei mir
aber noch eine ältere Version ohne ZigBee
vielleicht haben auch nicht alle ZigBee
also aktuell hab ich so bei mir
also wenn das Ding über ZigBee
sendet ist natürlich super easy
dann brauchst du nur einen ZigBee-Stick am Home Assistant
und der bekommt das, das wäre natürlich top
so wie ich es aktuell gemacht hab ist
ich hab bei mir am Klo
also nicht am Klo
hinterm Klo
ne, beim Klo hängt das
so eine Box
Moment
Moment, Moment
jetzt
mach ich die Klappe nicht runter
man sieht's hier
das USB-Kabel geht
an einen ESP32
der hängt hier
hinterm Klo
am Klo hängt der
ESP32 ist so eine wasserdichte
Box
und der
empfängt permanent
BLE-Sachen
und schickt's weiter per Wifi an meinen Home Assistant
noch selbstgestrickte
Firmware die da drauf läuft
mittlerweile bekommt man von Home Assistant
Out of the Box fertige Firmware
für ESP32
als Bluetooth-Proxy
das hab ich noch selbst gebaut
schade dass ich hier nicht die
was ist hier für
diese Dü... ja ja Max
nicht die
ey ich mach ernsthaft
ich mach nie den Klo-Deckel runter
dann sieht man's nicht
aber hier hinter hängt der
so sieht's aus
und jetzt gucken wir uns mal an
was
die Wahrheit über Teemu
gucken wir uns jetzt mal an
also nachdem ich mich darüber ausgelassen hab
dass das Teemu aussieht wie jede weitere
China-Chinesen-Shop-Seite
und Chat ihr gebt mir doch recht oder
Teemu sieht aus wie jede weitere
China-Chinesen-Shop-Seite
also wer's jetzt hier nicht mitbekommen hat
das sind alles unterschiedliche China-Chinesen-Shops
und
die Dinger
sehen halt einfach exakt
gleich aus
China-Chinesen-Kram
let's go
Übrigens
das ist auch so ein Ding
das muss ich jetzt einfach mal loswerden
es gab ja mal ne ganze Weile
auf Youtube den Trend
wir haben Grafikkarten
bei Wish bestellt
der Wish-PC und Wish und sonst was
ganz ehrlich
für mich hat man
nichts gegen die Content-Creator
die das gemacht haben
aber dass das so beliebt ist
sagt mir, dass die meisten Leute
einfach unfähig sind
sich online zu bewegen
weil
es irgendwie halbwegs bei Verstand ist
würde Sachen bei Wish bestellen
Wish bevorzugen
versus AliExpress zum Beispiel
Wish ist einfach nur AliExpress
für die Leute, die zu dumm sind AliExpress zu bestellen
also Wish ist
AliExpress nur in schlecht und scammt
es ist deutlich besser direkt bei AliExpress
zu bestellen, dann hast du keine
shady Dropship-Dudes
mehr dazwischen
und du kriegst dein Kram und
das Beste bei AliExpress ist
ein ziemlich
wie soll man das am besten sagen
ein ziemlich scharfen
Kundensupport
also mit scharf meine ich jetzt nicht
dass die hotte Grills haben
oder so, vielleicht, weiß ich nicht
die sind sehr
darauf bedacht
dass man
nicht beschissen wird
um es mal klar zu sagen
ich hatte bei AliExpress mal
was bestellt, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr
was das gewesen ist, genau
ich weiß es wirklich nicht mehr, irgendwie
Elektronik-Kram, hatte ich
bestellt
hab ich nie bekommen
und dann habe ich bei AliExpress
wie bei Paypal so ein
Käuferschutz-Ticket aufgemacht
sowas hat AliExpress tatsächlich
glaubt man jetzt gar nicht
und hab da geschrieben
ich warte seit Wochen drauf
angeblich wurde es seit Wochen verschickt
und es kommt nicht an
und
dann hat sich dieser AliExpress
Käuferschutz eingeschaltet, hat den Shop
angeschrieben, der Shop hat mir
geantwortet, oh sie sind so very
sorry und
sie verschicken das jetzt nochmal
und hier ist meine neue Tracking-Nummer
die neue Tracking-Nummer war exakt die alte
Tracking-Nummer, die immer noch auf
ist auf
dem Weg zum Flughafen oder so
stand, also die haben mich einfach
gebatet, so und da hab ich den Tag
lang nicht geantwortet und noch
am gleichen Tag hat AliExpress geantwortet
wenn sie das Ticket
bis morgen nicht
akzeptiert schließen
erstatten wir ihnen das Geld zurück
Dima danke für den Sub, erstatten wir ihnen
das Geld zurück und da hab ich einen Tag
nicht reagiert und AliExpress
hat es direkt geclosed
mir das Geld zurück überwiesen und
wahrscheinlich den Shop
angeschissen was das soll
also ganz ehrlich
ich hatte weniger Probleme bisher
mit dem Käuferschutz von Ali
man glaubt das gar nicht, aber
ich hatte bisher weniger Probleme mit dem Käuferschutz
von AliExpress
wie mit dem Käuferschutz von Paypal
würde man nicht glauben
aber war bisher so
das ist natürlich nicht
repräsentativ, ich hab jetzt
nicht irgendwie hunderte Fälle von
Paypal, hunderte Fälle von AliExpress
jetzt hat er wegen mir einen
negativen Social Credit
Score, ja gut dann soll er halt
Leute auch nicht scammen und sein Kram los schicken
also bei Paypal
hatte ich beispielsweise mal ein Riesenproblem
da hab ich
bestellt bei, wie hießen die
CrowdFox, weiß nicht ob es
das überhaupt noch gibt, ne gibt's nicht mehr
Shop, gibt's nicht mehr
CrowdFox Shop, gibt's nicht mehr
gab es mal
CrowdFox
gibt's nicht mehr
zumindest
hab ich mir da mal einen Netzwerkschrank
bestellt
also mal gucken, Moment
ich such da mal auf Deutsch
bei AliExpress, mal gucken
was man da findet
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
AliExpress ist immer nicht die
hä
ist doch kein Netzwerkschrank
AliExpress hat
Warehouses in Deutschland
bin ich mir nicht sicher
ich weiß es nicht
aber AliExpress hat auf jeden Fall Warehouses
in Frankreich und in Spanien und
in den Niederlande
und du musst dir wegen Zoll
keine Gedanken machen, AliExpress
schickt das immer erst nach Spanien oder
erst in die Niederlande und von dort
dann zu dir, das heißt ich hatte bei
AliExpress noch nie Probleme mit dem
Zoll, bei den USA, bei Bestellung
aus den USA hatte ich immer
Probleme mit dem Zoll, vor allem
als ich mal was bestellt
habe bei
Adafruit war das, so ein
Microcontroller Zeug
die
habe ich bei der Bestellung sogar ausgewählt
dass ich möchte
dass DHL
den Papierkram mit dem Zoll abwickelt
und am Ende lief
daraus raus, dass das in Leipzig
hatte jemand schon mal Probleme mit DHL und
Zoll Leipzig? Voll für'n Arsch
alter, voll für'n Arsch
ich hab das per Express bestellt, weil ich das schnell haben
wollte, dann landet das beim Zoll
in Leipzig, DHL sollte das Ganze abwickeln
auf einmal krieg ich irgendwie ne Mail
vom Zoll, ich soll eintragen
was das ist und sowas
und da hab ich mir gedacht, Leute
ihr habt doch die Info was das ist und ihr
wolltet euch da doch drum kümmern
und da hab ich angerufen beim Zoll
bei DHL, Zoll bei diesen
DHL Leuten in Leipzig
und da hab ich die gefragt, was man da jetzt machen
soll und da war ihre Antwort
ja das kann ich
ihnen auch nur nichts sagen
da dachte ich mir auch so
alter Leute, ihr kriegt irgendwie
40 Euro für Versand und
Zollabwicklung und die einzige Aussage
die ich von mir, von euch bekomme
das kann ich euch auch jetzt, das kann ich ihnen
jetzt auch nichts sagen
das waren echt die Spezialisten
schlechthin DHL Zoll in Leipzig
äh, meine Güte
meine Güte
einzige was dann geholfen hat ist, ich konnte
nix machen, einzige was geholfen
ist, geholfen hat ist
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es Adafruit war
ich glaub es war Adafruit, ich hab die angeschrieben
hab gesagt, Leute, ich hab per Express bestellt
eigentlich sollte es ja innerhalb von 7 Tagen da sein
ich brauch das dringend
ich weiß, ihr könnt
nichts dafür, aber
DHL und der Zoll sind hochgradig unfähig
ich brauch das, mir bringt das in 3 Wochen
nichts mehr
das heißt, ich werd das direkt wieder
zurückgehen lassen und nicht annehmen, ich werd die Annahme
verweigern und
Paypal sagen, ich will das Geld wieder haben
wenn das jetzt nicht innerhalb
von ein paar Tagen kommt, weil ich brauch das
und ohne Scheiß, die haben dort
wohl angerufen, beim Zoll
und haben sich aufgeregt und einen Tag
später war es freigegeben
also, das muss man sagen
Kundenservice, das geht bei den Amis
wobei, die sind ja auch, sag mal so
im Prinzip haben sie wahrscheinlich
selbst dafür gesorgt, dass sie irgendwas nicht richtig ausgefüllt
haben und
in Kombination mit unfähigen Zoll
DHL Leuten, ganz, ganz weird champ
auf jeden Fall
äh, was hat das jetzt mit Rack, mit Netzwerk
Racks zu tun, bitteschön
Ultraschallreiniger, 2 Frequenz
Ultraschallreinigungsmaschine, digital
tragbare Waschmaschine
bester Produkttitel
haha
typischer China
typischer China-Chinesen
Produkttitel, alter
Ultraschallreiniger, 2 Frequenz
Ultraschallreinigungsmaschine, digitale
tragbare Waschmaschine
typischer China-Chinesen
Name, alter
die Dinger heißen immer so abgedreht
ich wollte eigentlich ein Netzwerk-Rack haben
ja, sowas hier
hohe Qualität
so
komm, wir suchen mal eher nach Rack
10 Zoll für Netzwerk
das findet AliExpress wahrscheinlich
besser
nein, das ist auch kein Rack
und das sieht eher aus
ich wollte, what the fuck
das sieht eher aus wie ein Audio-Rack
aber es ist anscheinend
ein
aha, Origin Place, China
Shenzhen, kommt das hier
wie immer, wenn die Autos
das sind irgendwelche Patchpanels
vielleicht soll ich nach
Inch suchen lieber, vielleicht können die das besser
6 Spielzeuge
genau das wollte ich jetzt suchen
AliExpress
ah ja
Hammer Rack, alles klar
ja sowas
zum Beispiel
sowas würde ich suchen
zumindest um die Geschichte
mit DHL nochmal kurz abzuschließen
ich hab so ein ähnliches Ding bei
nicht mit DHL, Crowdfox
und UPS und Paypal
Kundenschutz, ich hab so ein Ding
bestellt als 19 Zoll
Schrank
und irgendwann kam der
UPS-Typ an und bringt mir das
und der, ich hätte es damals
ahnen müssen, hab ich aber nicht
geahnt, ja sehr günstig
hab ich aber nicht geahnt
der hat super versucht, super
unauffällig zu gucken
der UPS-Typ
um das Paket möglichst wenig zu bewegen
und nachdem ich unterschrieben hab
ist der auch zackig abgehauen
und irgendwann hab ich's dann
gecheckt, ich hab das Ding
ausgepackt
und auf einmal rieselt mir das
Glas entgegen
von der vorderen Tür
und das ist ja so ein Glas, das reißt
nicht einfach, wenn das bricht
dann bröselt, vielleicht wisst ihr
wie man das nennt
also das ist ein Glas, das kriegt keine Risse
das bröselt einfach, das zerbröselt einfach
in tausend Teile
und da hatte ich halt in diesem Karton
auf einmal
irgendwie tausende Bröckchen
Glas drinnen liegen, also was hab ich
gemacht, rein fotografiert
in den Karton, hab gesagt
so, hier nehm ich das nicht
hab an Crowdfox geschrieben
Ersatz oder zurückschicken
oder Geld zurück, mir egal
aber in der Form kann ich das nicht gebrauchen
kam kaputt an
Crowdfox
schickt mir
deswegen gibt's den Job wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr
Crowdfox schickt mir so ein Formular zurück
was man ausfüllen soll für Rücksende Etikett
ich füll das aus, schick denen das hin
keine Reaktion
ich frag nochmal nach, keine Reaktion
so, also was hab ich gemacht
Paypal, Kunden, Dingsbums, Service
Paypal auch mal wieder
hunderte Sachen hochladen müssen
dass die überhaupt diesen
Konfliktlösungsfall eröffnen
dann hat Paypal
zu mir gesagt, und wenn sie die Sachen
bis da und da nicht einreichen
dann wird das automatisch geschlossen, das Gegenteil
von AliExpress, AliExpress hat gesagt
wenn sie nicht das OK
markiert haben
kommt der Shopbesitzer ins Arbeitslager
quasi
zumindest hab ich das bei Paypal
alles eingereicht, das hat gedauert
hat gedauert, hat gedauert
und irgendwann lief dieser Paypal-Kundenschutzding
ab
und am letzten Tag
wo dieses Paypal-Kundenschutzding offen war
und der Shop
Zeit hatte drauf zu antworten
hat mich jemand von Crowdfox angerufen
und hat gesagt
wenn man ihnen das Geld zurückerstattet
behalten sie das Ding
oder schmeißen sie es weg
das Zurückschicken ist ja noch teurer
als sonst was
eigentlich hätte ich jetzt
drauf sagen können, aber ich bestehe auf
Entsorgung oder irgendwas blödsinniges
hat gesagt, ja passt, mach ich
und dann hatte ich quasi
einen Netzwerkschrank ohne Tür, den ich behalten
konnte, für umsonst
aber ich hab den nie verwendet, ich hab den irgendwann
auf einen Schrott
auf einen Sammelhof gebracht
also wie gesagt, mit Paypal hatte ich bisher
Stress, mit AliExpress, was das angeht
noch nicht
Nun gut, so, eigentlich
lange Rede, kurzer Sinn
eigentlich wollte ich das Video gucken
Moment, Werbung Intel
Guck mal hier
wir haben ganz viel Zeug bei Temu gestellt
zum Beispiel ein Smartboard für 14,84 Euro
und ein Puls-
Das
ohne Scheiß, das sieht
nicht so aus, als ist das
was, was ich will, dass es mir in den Finger
sticht, wobei sticht das mir überhaupt
in den Finger? Ne, macht's nicht
das ist wahrscheinlich das gleiche, was
meine Garmin Uhr macht
und
also diese, kann ich euch vielleicht auch
mal kurz erklären
diese Puls-Mess-
Uhren, eigentlich
sind die ja hauptsächlich für Läufer gedacht
aber die kann man ja auf das Fahrrad fahren
und sowas, diese Puls-Mess-Uhren
seht ihr, wie die funktionieren?
Die sind richtig, das ist richtig high IQ
die haben hinten, sowas hier
also
ursprünglich dachte ich irgendwie, die messen
den Puls mit dem Band
aber das funktioniert natürlich nicht richtig
das ist ja, ist ja, ist ja
kann ja nicht funktionieren, ist ja nicht mehr
Ne, das funktioniert folgendermaßen
das hat hier so ne
eine LED
und ein
Kamera, sagen wir mal
sagen wir mal ganz einfach gesagt
das ist eine LED und eine Kamera, ist es nicht
aber so in der Richtung
es ist eine LED und eine Kamera
und was die machen ist, die leuchten dir
in den Arm rein und dann
gucken die auf dem
Kamerabild, wie weit
deine
Gefäße in den oberen
Hautschichten sind
und versuchen auch ungefähr zu analysieren
wie so der
der Blutfluss
in deinen Gefäßen
in den oberen Hautschichten ist
und daraus können die ableiten
wie hoch gerade dein Puls und dein
Stresslevel ist und sowas
das ist auch Haut
Leitfähigkeit und Zeug, das ist eigentlich
man glaubt nicht, dass das genau
ist, ja und das ist sicherlich
auch nicht so genau wie ein Pulsgurt
gerade was kurzfristige
schnelle Änderungen angeht oder es ist
bestimmt auch nicht so genau
wie wenn du das mit
EKG und alles und super genau
aber es ist doch
ziemlich genau, es gibt Tests, dass
sich das im Bereich von
96, 97%
Genauigkeit bewegt, also
sprich, wenn du einen Puls von 150
hast, dann ist das halt vielleicht
in Wirklichkeit
151 oder 149
oder noch nicht mal 149
5, aber es ist
wirklich sehr genau
und das würde man eigentlich gar nicht glauben
dieser Technik, aber da sieht man mal
nur weil man was nicht glauben kann
heißt es noch lange nicht, dass es falsch ist
und nicht funktionieren können muss, ja
Flacherde, mal so
zum Beispiel, die sagen ja auch
ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen, ich glaub das
alles nicht, deswegen ist die Erde flach, ja
logisch
Keck Alu, man
Die Apple Watches, die sind
tatsächlich noch ein Tick genauer
die sind sogar
noch ein bisschen genauer
aber auch sehr teuer
und haben auch keine lange Akkulaufzeit
also ganz ehrlich, für Sport
und gerade fürs Laufen ist so eine Garmin
Watch finde ich persönlich angenehmer
als eine
Apple Uhr, wenn man natürlich
wenn man natürlich
den ganzen Tag an hat und damit
auch die ganzen Apple Smart
Funktionen verwenden möchte
dann ist vielleicht eine Apple Watch sinniger
wobei man sagen muss
man kann ja auch mit der Garmin Uhr bezahlen
und bisschen die Musik steuern am Handy
und so, ich finde das gar nicht so schlecht
Preis-Leistungs-mäßig ist
gerade die etwas günstigere
die günstigen
Forerunners sind
ganz okay, mein günstig ist
relativ, ja
die kosten immer noch
unsinnig viel
aber das geht
noch halbwegs, so eine Apple Watch kostet
wie viel? 900?
Ja das ist die SE, was kosten
die normale?
Series 8?
Das geht doch sogar, geht eigentlich ganz gut, klar
geht doch eigentlich halbwegs
ist günstiger als ich gedacht hätte
aber jetzt gucken wir endlich mal das Video
sonst wird das echt nichts mehr
okay, ein Puls-Oximeter
Oximeter für 2,69 Euro
oder hier eine elektrische Kettensäge
für 11 Euro
Ja, das wollte ich mir auch
schon immer mal bei AliExpress bestellen
0,49 Euro
Ich würde mir wahrscheinlich entweder
Hä, Temu, was ist das denn?
Oder wenn ihr viel auf Social Media abhängt
Oh Gott, ständig nur Temu, ich kann es nicht mehr sehen
WTF
Weil Temu macht extrem viel Werbung
auch mit Influencern
Nervige Temu-Werbung habe ich auch schon bekommen
Ob wir nicht gegen Bezahlung
was Gutes über Temu sagen wollen
Moment, das ist garantiert typische China-Chines
Ich muss mal gucken, mich würde nicht wundern
Lass mich mal schauen
Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn ich auch sowas gekriegt hätte
Also es kommt nämlich
öfters vor, dass ich China-Chinesen
Temu
Nein, von Temu habe ich noch nichts gekriegt, okay
Oh Moment, ich bin auch in der falschen E-Mail
Ich bin komplett falsche E-Mail-Adresse
Temu
Nein, Temu habe ich noch nichts gekriegt
Dann wird es mal Zeit, Chatge
Ich kriege ansonsten die
schädigsten Anfragen von irgendwelchen Herstellern
Key-Shops sind in letzter Zeit wieder voll am Start
Und anderes
China-Chinesen-Zeug
Aber
HelloFresh wollte auch, aber jetzt will HelloFresh
nicht mehr, bzw. wir waren ein bisschen zu spät
Es gibt kein HelloFresh mehr
Okay
Auf geht's
Brauchen wir bestimmt ein iPhone zu
Ja, eine Apple Watch ohne iPhone ist doof
Wobei man ehrlich sagen muss
Die
Garmin-Uhr ganz ohne App
Auf dem Smartphone
Wobei das auch Android sein kann
Ist das auch ein bisschen doof
Die Uhr funktioniert komplett autark
Ohne alles, ja
Aber beispielsweise gerade
Um
Sich mal
Statistik anzugucken
Apps, neue Datenfelder drauf zu installieren
Und sowas
Das ist ohne Handy alles doof
Das geht mit dem PC auch, das geht teilweise sogar bei den teureren Uhren
Direkt von der Uhr
Aber
Wenn man auch mal so seine
Entwicklung von Zeiten verfolgen will
Dann ist das mit dem Handy schon deutlich angenehmer
So
Die Antwort darauf seht ihr in diesem Video
Und auch ob die Sachen, die wir bestellt haben, was taugen
Spoiler, wir haben das Geld natürlich nicht angenommen
Achso, achso, achso
Und vielen Dank
Achso, was haben sie ihnen denn geboten
Viele YouTuber arbeiten mit uns
Temu, senden sie uns eine
Ach, Honorarvorstellung
Ja, das machen die gerne
Die Antwort darauf seht ihr in diesem Video
Und auch ob die Sachen, die wir bestellt haben, was taugen
Spoiler, wir haben das Geld natürlich nicht angenommen
Achso, achso, achso
Und vielen Dank an euch alle für 100.000 Abos
Wir haben uns richtig, richtig
DJ Eats kratzt
Und ja, jetzt sind wir motiviert
Hallo liebe Hackerin
Liebe Hackerin
Liebe Internetsurfer
Oder so
Herzlich willkommen hier bei
Okay, auf geht's
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von Intel
Habt ihr vor, einen neuen Rechner für euer Unternehmen
Ja, Temu
Die Temu App ist in den Appstores von Android
Und Apple IOS zur Zeit
Die am meisten heruntergeladen
Warum?
Platz 1 in beiden Stores
Aber was ist Temu denn jetzt überhaupt
Das sind Leute, die unfähig sind, bei AliExpress zu bestellen
Das gleiche wie bei Wish
AliExpress bei Wish bestellt
Hat ein Kollege im Österreich
Das ist ein guter
Und das trifft es ganz gut
Temu ist eine Versandplattform, wo vieles noch
billiger ist, als bei Wish
Oder AliExpress
Und bunter und gamifizierter
Lockt man sich da ein, dreht sich erstmal ein Glücksrad
Bei dem man dann Rabatte gewinnt
Ja, und generell wird man auf der Website
An jeder Ecke mit irgendwelchen Funktionen
Einmal Kopfzug bestellen, auf geht's
Und es wird immer so getan, als müsste man sich richtig beeilen
Weil die Angebote gleich ablaufen
Das ist normal
Das haben wir bei AliExpress auch
Ist nicht demnächst wieder
Black Friday, Cyber Monday
Day, Week, Weekend, Monat
Die Holdings
Registriert auf den Cayman Islands
Und gegründet vom chinesischen Milliardär
Und die große Frage, die wir uns gestellt haben
Warum ist das so erfolgreich
Was macht Temu besser, als die anderen Billigläden
Aus China
Ja, es ist halt noch ein bisschen billiger
Und das geht nur, weil Temu drauf zahlt
Pro Bestellung verliert Temu
Durchschnittlich 30 US-Dollar
Das schreibt ebenfalls
Das meines Erachtens durchaus vertrauenswürdige
US-Magazin Wired
Und laut Wired wurden diese 30 Dollar
Auch von einem Firmeninsider bestehen
Nun kann man jetzt sagen, ja okay, die wollen halt Wachstum
Um jeden Preis, um die Konkurrenz auszuschalten
Aber was das Ganze gerade vor diesem Hintergrund
Ziemlich gruselig macht
Ist, dass die App womöglich auch spioniert
Hier, diesen sehr ausführlichen Bericht
Findet man auf der Webseite
Wer hätte das nur vermutet
Wir glauben, dass PDD ein sterbendes
Betrügerisches Unternehmen ist
Und seine Shopping-App Temu
Versteckte Spyware, die eine dringende
Sicherheitsbedrohung für die nationalen
Interessen der USA darstellt
Grizzly Research sagt, sie haben in der
Temu-App etliche versteckte Funktionen
gefunden, mit denen sich unter anderem
beliebiger Code ausführt
Der potenziell von Temu-Servern gesendet wird
Nun muss man dazu sagen, dass es sich bei
Grizzly Research um Short-Seller handelt
Das sind also Leute, die auf fallende
Kurse von Börsennotierungen
Einmal ganz davon abgesehen, normalerweise sollte
Eigentlich Apple bei einem App-Review
Das checken
Aber vielleicht bezieht sich das auch nicht auf die iOS-App
Sondern auf die Android-App
Google
Ist ja da nicht ganz so kritisch
Profitieren, wenn der Aktienkurs fällt
Grizzly hat also ein Interesse daran
Temu schlecht zu machen, das sollte man
Wissen. Ich hab mir allerdings auch angeguckt
Was das automatische Sicherheitsanalyse-Tool
Joe Sandbox zur Temu-Android-App
Ausgibt und das ist ebenfalls
Besorgniserregend. Die Einstufung ist
Malicious, also bösartig
Found Potential
Found Potential Keylogger
Sim-Provider
Obfuscated
Also das sieht schon echt
Bisschen fragwürdig aus
Bisschen sehr fragwürdig aus
Da poppen
Etliche Red-Flags auf
Allerdings werden andere Shopping-Apps wie die von Amazon
Ebenfalls als bösartig eingestuft
Also auch das hier ist jetzt kein
Untrüglicher Beweis dafür
Dass die Temu-App illegale Dinge tut
Aber es ist zumindest ein Indiz
Und ich will hier jetzt nicht mit irgendwelchen Verschwörungstheorien
Um die Ecke kommen, aber ich persönlich
Finde die Kombination aus potenziell
Gefährlicher App, die womöglich so viel
Persönliche Daten absaugen will wie möglich
Und einer Firma mit Servern in China
Die bewusst drauf zahlt, damit sie
Stimmt schon, ne?
Sehr problematisch
Deshalb schon mal jetzt die ganz klare Empfehlung
Wenn ihr Temu unbedingt nutzen wollt, dann macht das
Über die Temu-Website, nicht über die App
Leute, Leute
Es ist keine Pfeife, die man hier bestellen kann
Moment
Warum kann ich hier ne G18 bestellen?
Und passend dazu
Die
Vermummungs-Demonstrations-Auto-Anzündungsmützen
Temu unbedingt
Wisst ihr was mich auch skeptisch macht?
Dass man keine Pfeife bestellen kann
Sondern eine Rauchröhre
Da stand halt Pipe oder sowas
Ursprünglich drinne
Es ist eine Rauchröhre
Was ist das?
Falsche Zunge
Simuliert Zunge
Okay
Ich versuch mir gerade
Eine Situation vorzustellen
In welcher Situation
Muss man sein
Dass man
Zu Temu geht
Sich eine falsche Zunge bestellt
Wann braucht man eine falsche
Zunge?
Zauberer
Einfach wieder High IQ
Ihr wisst sofort Bescheid
Zauberer, ja habt ihr recht
Halloween, ja okay
Chat, ich verstehe
Es klingt, ja ihr habt recht
Klingt nachvollziehbar
Nicht über die App
So haben wir das jedenfalls gehandhabt
Zumindest hat man dann das App als Wanze Problem
Wenigstens ein bisschen verringert
Dann muss man nur noch damit zurecht kommen
Dass das Zeug auf der Website in Fabriken
Mit fragwürdigen Arbeitsbedingungen produziert wird
Zwangsarbeit
Ein US Kongress Ausschuss schrieb in einem Bericht
China Shop halt
Dass die Lieferketten durch Zwangsarbeit
Kontaminiert seien
Ja, okay
Das sind jetzt schon ziemlich viele Gründe
Niemals bei Temu zu bestellen
Ich hab letztens gelesen
Ein Artikel drüber
Ich glaube das kommt von der EU
Dass die EU jetzt
Shops die
Waren aus China
Neue Auflagen machen will
Und zwar
Wie gesagt, ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher
Wie es genau ist
Wenn ich es genau wissen wollte
Glaubt mir nicht alle, sondern guckt nochmal nach
Aber ich glaube das ist so
Die wollen jetzt eine Liste erstellen
Gegen Unterdrückung und
Menschenausbeutung und sowas
Die wollen eine Liste erstellen mit Shops
Und
Produkten beziehungsweise
Regionen
Das neue Lieferkettengesetz
Mit Shops, mit Regionen
Und mit Produkten
Die
In Verdacht stehen
Menschen auszubeuten
Und
Um dem zu entgehen
Sollen dann die Hersteller
Beweisen
Dass die Lieferketten
Nicht durch Menschenausbeutung
Irgendwie
Unterstützt werden
So
Das ist
Du
Verstehst
Wie willst du, ich meine, ich stelle euch mal vor, ihr seid dort Zwangsarbeiter und der Typ, und der Typ kommt
Der Chef von dir kommt zu dir und sagt, hey, unterschreib mal hier, dass du kein Zwangsarbeiter bist
Und dann sagst du dann, aber ich bin doch Zwangsarbeiter
Und dann sagt dein Chef, okay, jetzt kommst du die nächsten drei Tage gar nicht mehr aus dem Käfig raus, wenn du nicht unterschreibst
Und dann wird dann der Zwangsarbeiter sagen, ja, okay, dann unterschreibe ich halt, dass ich kein Zwangsarbeiter bin
Und dann gibt er das ab und sagen die dann, ah, okay, die Zwangsarbeiter haben unterschrieben, dass sie keine Zwangsarbeiter sind
Ja, dann kann es keine Zwangsarbeit sein, alles okay, Import läuft
Ich frage mich halt, wie das laufen soll, wie soll das überhaupt kontrolliert, geschweige denn, wie kann man
Also, von der Idee ist das ja wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal so schlecht gedacht, dass man sowas machen will
Ich stelle es mir aber enorm schwierig vor, wie man das umsetzt
Naja, also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das irgendwie realistisch funktioniert
Aber da das da draußen offenbar trotzdem sehr viele Leute machen, haben wir nach vielen Diskussionen beschlossen, uns zumindest mal ein bisschen von dem Zeug anzugucken
Was man bei Teemo zu Billigpreisen kaufen kann
Und ja, ich habe mich nicht wohl dabei gefühlt, aber ich wollte ja auch keinen Journalismus betreiben, der nur in der Theorie herumstochert
Sie hätten ja ein Video machen können, weil sie so viele AI-Videos haben
Sie hätten ein Video machen können, ich frage Chat-GPT, was ich bei Teemo bestellen soll
Also, die Fakten
Wir haben für 365,48 Euro Dinge gekauft
Die sind in drei Plastikküken verteilt angekommen
Die erste kam sieben Tage nach Bestellung, die zweite nach neun Tagen
Und die dritte nach 14 Tagen
Das ist für China-Versand relativ schnell, sofern es aus China kommt
Weiß nicht, ob Teemo nicht auch irgendwelche Lager in der EU hat und sowas
Also, für China ist das gar nicht langsam
Also, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, als ich bei China Mainland bestellt habe, dass das wirklich aus China mit dem Schiff losgeschickt wird
Da hast du durchaus mal einen Monat drauf gewartet
Manchmal sogar auch ein bisschen länger, so teilweise 45 Tage oder so
Das hat schon ein bisschen gedauert
Das konnte man auch nur bei Dingen machen, die halt nicht super dringend waren
Also, die ersten Sachen, die ich bei AliExpress bestellt habe, das waren ganz viele Elektronik-Sachen
Da habe ich schon eine Weile drauf gewartet, aber die waren halt auch super günstig
Man kann bei AliExpress, by the way, wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich zeige mal
Man kann bei AliExpress, wundert euch nicht
Hier, die Suche ändert sich immer und die Suche wird immer mehr pp-iger und immer merkwürdiger
Die ändert sich auch
Ihr könnt auswählen, Versand von Deutschland, wobei oftmals Versand aus Frankreich und Spanien vielversprechender ist
Zumindest war das noch zu Zeiten, wo ich bei AliExpress öfters bestellt habe, so
Die haben mehr Warenlager gehabt in UK, Spanien, Frankreich und hier Tschechien als in Deutschland
Und bei Banggood kann man das Ganze auch auswählen, da konnte man irgendwo einstellen
Warenlager, irgendwie Versand von...
Liefern von Polen konnte man dann zum Beispiel einstellen
Chat
Hast du aber nicht bei AliExpress bestellt, oder?
Wisst ihr, was das längste Produkt war, wo ich in meinem Leben jemals drauf gewartet habe?
Ihr kommt nicht drauf, ich sage es euch, rein rhetorische Frage, was das gewesen ist
Und das war damals für den Super Nintendo, Secret of Evermore
Für den Super Nintendo
Da habe ich Wochen und Monate drauf gewartet
Und das hat auch für mich meine Abneigung gegen Elektronik Einzelhandel bestärkt
Ich habe das bei so einem kleinen Elektronikladen bei mir um die Ecke bestellt
Ich meine, das war 1996 oder sowas
Und da war halt mit Bestell mal irgendwo bei einem größeren Shop nichts
Das hast du bei kleinen, da hast du deine Super Nintendo Spiele bei kleineren Elektronikläden bestellt
Und
Die haben Wochen gebraucht
Aber wahrscheinlich auch, weil Nintendo die nicht richtig beliefert oder sowas
Wochen, Alter
Ich bin da wirklich mehrfach wöchentlich hingelaufen und habe gefragt, ob es mittlerweile da ist
Ganz im Ernst, die hätten auch einfach anrufen können, wenn es da ist
Also Nintendo hat sich scheiße angestellt damals und der Shop hat sich ultra dumm angestellt
Also das hat zum Großteil mit dazu beigetragen, dass ich keinen Bock habe auf Elektronik Einzelhandel mehr
Also dass ich damals schon eine riesen Abneigung gegen Elektronik Einzelhandel hatte
Aber jetzt gucken wir uns das Video endlich mal fertig
So ein Countdown runterzählt
Das macht AliExpress auch
Ach ja
Ja, einfach random Zeug bestellen, das senkt CO2 immer
Also falls ihr es noch nicht wusstet, immer random Scheiß bestellen, den ihr nicht braucht für die Umwelt
Easy
Ach so funktioniert das
So funktioniert das, ich sollte beim nächsten Black Friday unbedingt noch meine Pakete voll machen
Aber wo wir wieder beim Punkt sind
Was man daran schön sieht ist, dass dieses ganze Umweltthema mittlerweile so omnipräsent ist
Und dementsprechend einfach auch schlicht und ergreifend von vielen nur noch zum Geld machen benutzt wird
Ja, wenn ich auf Twitter irgendwelche Ölkonzerne sehe, die neuerdings Werbung schalten
Wie super krass umweltfreundlich sie sind
Irgendwelche Autohersteller, Versandhändler, alle haben sie mittlerweile ihr Herz für die Umwelt und Grünsein entdeckt
Und haben dann im Zweifelsfall auch irgendwelche schönen, superhippen Werbefilmchen
Wie viele Bäume sie schon gepflanzt haben und sowas
Letztendlich, die Umwelt geht denen sowas von am Arsch vorbei
Genauso wie viele andere, sagen wir mal Mainstream-Themen, denen sowas von am Arsch vorbeigehen
Das hieß zum Beispiel schon daran, wenn du dir anguckst, dass Blizzard auf der einen Seite ankommt mit
Diversity, Black-Life-Matters und sonst was und auf der anderen Seite
In China Leuten das Preisgeld aberkennt, äh in Taiwan Leuten das Preisgeld aberkennt
Weil sie irgendwie, Hongkong, sorry nicht Taiwan, Hongkong
Weil sie gesagt haben, Freiheit für Hongkong
Also man sieht, dass es einfach nur
Äh, ja so, so den jeweiligen Zeitgeist in der jeweiligen Region gefüttert
Den Unternehmen ist das scheißegal
Ich will nicht ausschließen, dass es durchaus auch welche gibt, denen es tatsächlich um die eigentliche Sache geht
Ein bisschen hast du ja, manchmal hast du ja immer noch Leute, die ein bisschen idealistisch rangehen
Aber egal, welche so aktuellen Zeitgeist-Themen es sind
Letztendlich wird einfach das gesagt, was in der jeweiligen Region hip ist, angesagt ist
Und die jeweiligen Unternehmen gut dastehen lässt und sie unterm Strich mehr verkaufen lässt
Wenn das morgen anders aussieht, scheißen sie wieder drauf
Also da muss man, also ich glaube, das Beste, was man echt machen kann, ist prinzipiell diesen ganzen Scheiß
Egal, ob es jetzt was ist, was man persönlich gut findet oder was ist, was man persönlich scheiße findet
Einfach nicht glauben, es dient letztendlich nur dazu, um euch die Sachen schmackhaft zu machen
Wobei ich da immer noch sagen muss, ich bin da ein bisschen hin und her, ein bisschen, ich habe da noch keine klare Antwort für mich persönlich draufgefunden
Weil ich habe ein sehr schlüssiges Argument gehört, auf Twitter Leute, man kann sich das gar nicht vorstellen, auf Twitter
Ein sehr schlüssiges Argument gehört mal von einem auf Twitter
Da gibt es auch Leute, die noch normale Sachen schreiben, aber das ist, und außerdem heißt es ja nicht auf X, sorry, auf X Leute, auf X
Ähm, habe ich ein sehr schlüssiges Argument gehört, genau zu dieser Thematik
Weil ich auch mal gesagt habe, auf irgendeiner Nachricht als Antwort auf Twitter, letztendlich denen geht es überhaupt nicht darum, um die gute Sache
Ja, wie gesagt, gute Sache ist ja immer so im Auge des Betrachters, der sich darüber Gedanken macht
Sondern denen geht es einfach nur ums Geld verdienen, da hat einer gesagt, Max, eigentlich ist das doch aber gar nicht so schlecht
Weil, auch wenn einer was macht, nur um Geld damit zu verdienen, so für die gute Sache
Unterm Strich war es doch immer noch was Positives
Da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, eigentlich, eigentlich gar nicht so verkehrt, oder?
Ich meine, ob, ob man die Sachen jetzt gut findet, deswegen, egal was es ist, das liegt ja immer in demjenigen, der sich es anguckt
Also ihr findet bestimmt andere Sachen gut oder schlecht als ich
Aber wenn ich mir eine Sache angucke und denke, okay, die Unternehmen werben damit, die machen das ja sicherlich nicht, weil sie überzeugt sind
Sondern einfach nur, um mehr Kohle zu machen
Aber unterm Strich, wenn sie dann Sachen dadurch fördern, die mir wichtig sind, warum nicht?
Ja, also, ich fand das Argument eigentlich gar nicht so verkehrt
Auf der anderen Seite ist aber auch wieder genau umgedreht
Ja, guckt euch, guckt euch Gronkh an, der geshitstormt wurde, weil er Hogwarts Legacy spielen wollte
Und das spenden wollte
Da war das wiederum nicht okay, dass man gesagt hat, okay, aber letztendlich kommt es doch einer guten Sache
Zu Gute, also anscheinend ist das gerade auf Twitter immer sehr abhängig davon, auf welche Blase es gerade trifft
Ja, ob das jetzt als gut oder als schlecht angesehen wird
Ich kann mir da immer noch keinen Reim drauf machen
Ist es jetzt gut, wenn Unternehmen was in Anführungszeichen Gutes machen, auch wenn sie sich einfach nur mehr Kohle davon erhoffen
Oder ist es einfach nur, ja, wir machen das, was dem aktuellen Zeitgeist in der Region am ehesten entspricht, um mehr Kohle zu machen
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es gut oder schlecht finden soll, keine Ahnung
So, jetzt gucken wir aber das Video weiter
Ja, aber wie gesagt, wir haben jetzt gelernt, die Kartons möglichst voll machen, am besten mit sinnlosem Plastik China-Chinesen-Zeug
Das reduziert die CO2-Emissionen
Ja, und natürlich pflanzen die Umweltaktivisten von Temu auch ganz viele Bäume, also alles super
Zur Sicherheit, das war ironisch gemeint
Und jetzt zu den Sachen, die da angekommen sind
Das Zeug wird ganz...
Ja, ja, und das, was du als extra Artikel reinlegst, um die CO2-Emissionen zu reduzieren, das kommt dann wahrscheinlich als extra Paket
Da hast du so unter 50 Euro Pleite
Stark, wie das, was Wish und AliExpress aufliefern
Vielleicht aber noch eine Idee schrottiger
Schaut euch alleine mal den Kunststoff von diesem Mini-Versiegelungsgerät an
Wisst ihr, wie das aussieht?
Der Kunststoff sieht aus, als dass du Hautausschlag bekommst von der puren Berührung
So sieht das aus
Das Anfassen alleine ist giftig
Ja, das stinkt
Das musst du die ersten 14 Tage draußen lagern, damit du es überhaupt, wenn du es nur in den Schrank legst, bei dir im Bad zum Beispiel
Das nicht schon morgens, wenn du ins Bad reinkommst, riechst
Für 1,78 Euro an
Aber ja, das Ding schmilzt
Plastiktüren zu lassen
Also Bäume pflanzen hilft auf jeden Fall
So diese Sachen mit
Für jedes verkaufte Bier pflanzen wir einen Baum
Da bin ich skeptisch, ob das hilft
Aber Bäume pflanzen an sich hilft auf jeden Fall
Das funktioniert
Auch wenn es dabei natürlich einen ziemlich üblen Geruch verströmt
Und hier jetzt die Smartwatch für knapp 25 Euro
Die hat mein Kollege Luke
Ey, okay, im Bildschirm schoner sieht die gar nicht so kacke aus
Man könnte, man könnte sagen
Das Gehäuse ist ein wenig von der Apple Watch inspiriert, oder?
So von Größe und Form und sonst was
Nur, dass das Gehäuse und das Band
Allein schon hier von dem
Deutlich billiger verarbeitet wirkt
Und das jetzt schon auf dem Video
Wenn man das Ding erstmal am Arm hat
Wirkt das wahrscheinlich wie
Ja
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie auf Wish bestellt
Aber es ist ja noch schlimmer als auf Wish bestellt
Lukas, der ist großer Smartwatch-Fan
Jetzt einige Wochen getragen
Und am anderen Arm die Apple Watch Ultra
Und dass das jetzt schon ein krasser Unterschied sein muss
Allein wegen des Preises, klar
Aber was dann relativ schnell aufgefallen ist
Das sind Fake-Daten
Wollen wir wetten, wollen wir wetten
Die zeigt, die zeigt, die zeigt einfach nur Müll an
Die, die Smartwatch, das ist die einfach random generated Daten
Die hat überhaupt keine Sensoren drin
Integrierten Sensoren für Puls und Blutsauerstoff
Messen gar nicht wirklich
Die Ergebnisse sind
Das dachte ich mir
Genau das dachte ich mir, Alter
Die China-Chinesen, man
Ich, ich hab kein China-E-Mode
Wir brauchen mal ein China-E-Mode, Leute
Ich hab nur das Gekommenet-E-Mode
Das ist das, was am nächsten rankommt
Warum haben wir eigentlich kein China-Chinesen-Shop-E-Mode hier?
Es ist zwar immerhin ähnlich zur Apple Watch
Allerdings sind sie das auch, wenn man die Demo-Smartwatch an einem Gummiarm hält
Also ist diese Smartwatch für diese ganzen Gesundheits-
Ist einfach nur random Daten, dieses Ding generiert
Können Smartwatches wirklich die Sauerstoff-Zettigung auslesen?
Ähm
Naja
Also, ich hab ja gerade erklärt, wie das bei der Forerunner-Uhr funktioniert
Die können
Die können nicht wirklich
Die können dir nicht, die pieksen dir nicht in den Arm und werten das dann aus
Was die machen ist
Die haben quasi, hab ich ja gerade, hab ich gerade
Die haben quasi, die haben quasi eine LED und eine Kamera drin
Leuchten die durch die Haut
Und messen dann quasi anhand
Der Durchgängigkeit, der Gefäßweite
Des Blutflusses und sowas
Und der Hautleitfähigkeit und sowas
Messen die dann
Puls, Stresslevel
Blutsauerstoff und sowas
Das
Das funktioniert natürlich nicht so genau
Wie wenn dir jetzt jemand ins Ohrläppchen sticht
Oder in den Finger sticht und das misst
Aber
Es funktioniert aus einem Grund
Doch ganz gut
Und das ist
Weil die eine sehr große
Ein sehr großes Datensammel
Also sehr viel Daten gesammelt haben
Und die
Paaren die mit echten Auswertungen
Also
Hab ich letztens erst was drüber gelesen
Zum Beispiel
Die ganzen Fitnesswerte
Die die ganzen Fitnessuhren anzeigen
Da sind ja so Sachen dabei wie
Das kann die Uhr nicht messen, ja
Äh
Lactatlevel und so
Woher
Woher soll
Woher soll das die Uhr wissen, ja
Die Uhr sticht dir nicht in den Arm und misst dann nix
Oder
Wie viel Sauerstoff du maximal auf
Das
Die kann deine Atemluft nicht analysieren
Und sowas
Das kann die Uhr eigentlich nicht direkt messen
Was die Uhr aber
Oder
Beziehungsweise
Was die Hersteller dieser Uhren aber machen können ist
Ähm
Ja mir geht es jetzt nicht um Blutsauerstoff
Mir geht es um noch viel mehr Werte die das anzeigen
Was die
Was die Uhren machen
Ähm
Ist
Die haben eine riesengroße Datenlage
Von
Also
Riesengroße Datentopf
Von ganz vielen Leuten die diese Uhr benutzen
Und das reichern die an mit
Echten Tests
Also sprich
Die zeichnen
Die zeichnen euch auf
Die zeichnen ganz viele Leute auf
Also die haben enorm viele Daten
Und dann machen die Tests
Mit echten Sportlern
Und
Ähm
Also
Mit
Mit einer großen Gruppe aus allen möglichen
Ja
Fitnessgraden
Machen die quasi echte Tests
Mit echten Sportlern
Also mit Atemmaske auf
Mit den Fingerstechen
Mit ins Ohrläppchen stechen
Mit Rennen
Mit Fahrradfahren
Und dann
Gleichen die das ab
Mit den Daten die sie haben
Und dadurch dass die so einen riesen Daten
Datenpool haben
Angereichert mit
Informationen aus echten Messungen
Können die
Halbwegs gut prädikten
Wenn die wissen
Du bist so groß
Du bist so schwer
Dein Maximal
Puls
Ist so und so hoch
Du schläfst so und so gut
Können die das relativ genau prädikten
Was deine Fitnesswerte sind
Das geht aber nur aufgrund der riesen Datenmenge
Und den live
Den live Auswertungen was sie mit echten Tests
Machen
Aber es ist gut genug
Es ist so gut dass der Puls beispielsweise
Im Bereich von 95, 97% ist
Und auch die so
VO2 Max Werte
Und Lactat Level
Das ist bei diesen ganzen Fitnessuhren
Erstaunlich genau
Obwohl die oftmals gar nicht die Möglichkeit haben
Direkt zu messen
So viel
Jetzt
Ist sie ungenauer wenn die Uhr offline ist
Ich würde mal sagen
Ein bisschen
Aber
Ich denke mal
Die Essenz aus vielen
Dieser Werten ist in der Firmware mittlerweile drin
Es ist nicht so dass die
Permanent Cloud Abgleich braucht
Hilft aber mit Sicherheit
Ja
Das ist absolut nicht geeignet
Und auch wenn die Uhr mehrere Trainingsmodi anbietet
Wenn die Messfunktion nicht funktioniert
Dann bringt das am Ende auch nichts
Ich bin begeistert Leute
Dass die Uhr überhaupt für 15 Euro ein Touchscreen hat
Die Vibration die man weniger spürt
Als hört
Aber immerhin kann die Smartwatch nach dem Verbinden mit dem Handy
Auch Nachrichten von Whatsapp, Signal
Wie heißt die App
Immerhin kann die Smartwatch nach dem Verbinden mit dem Handy
Auch Nachrichten von Whatsapp, Signal
Und sogar Teams anzeigen
Geht nur mit
China-Chinesen Cloud Servern oder
So Minispiele
Funktionieren eigentlich auch
Wenn man jetzt das Bedürfnis hat
Auf so einem Mini-Uhren-Display zu spielen
Habt ihr den Lack gesehen
Habt ihr den Input-Lack gesehen vom Touch-Display
Guckt euch das mal genau an
Wie krass der Input-Lack ist
Er hat jetzt getoucht
Der Finger ist schon wieder oben
Und
Moment, den ersten Touch hat er gar nicht mitbekommen
Wenn man jetzt das Bedürfnis hat
Auf so einem Mini-Uhren-Display
Das war bestimmt
250 Millisekunden
Delay
Touch
Hoch, Finger ist oben
Und jetzt geht das Ding
Erst hoch
250 Millisekunden Delay
Uhren-Display zu spielen
Die Preisgestaltung bei TEMO
Ist aber auch da
Wirklich mehr so Zufallsgeneriert
Wir haben zwei Smartwatches bestellt
Eine für knapp 15 und eine für knapp 25 Euro
Beide sind im Prinzip identisch
Das ist uns generell echt aufgefallen
Bei TEMO
Das ist aber bei China-Shops oft so
Dass oftmals das gleiche Produkt dahinter steckt
Wirken oft wie ausgewürfelt
Und verändern sich super schnell
Also klar Dynamic Pricing
Also das individuelle und oft sehr schnelle Anpassung von Preisen
Machen fast alle Online-Händler
Aber bei TEMO ist das echt nochmal Next Level
Das war für uns jetzt sogar schwierig beim Schreiben des Skripts
Wisst ihr was mal das abenteuerlichste Ding war
Was ich auf Aliexpress bestellt habe
Ich glaube das gibt es gar nicht mehr
PCI-Express
16-fach
Auf einfach
Äh Schwachsinn
Einfach auf 16-fach
Okay die sehen mittlerweile deutlich
Professioneller aus
Als das was ich mal bestellt habe
Bei Aliexpress
Die Dinger sind ja heute wenigstens ordentlich
Gelötet
Und das war
Ernsthaft geklebt mit
Klebeband
Das war super
Das habe ich nie verwendet
Aber das war super abenteuerlich
Das war quasi so ein Ding
So ein ähnliches Ding wie das hier
Nur dass das hier
Geklebt war mit Klebeband
Suchen wir mal nach
Aliexpress please
Extend
Und das war
Ja die sehen jetzt alle schon deutlich
Besser aus als den Schrott den ich damals
Bestellt habe
Ja
Sowas in der Richtung war das
So
War breiter
Würdet ihr es nicht auch
Direkt bei euch in den Rechner stecken
Komm gibt zu oder
Sieht so aus als will man das mal sich in den Rechner schieben oder
Sieht
Sieht toll aus
Wirklich sehr safe aus auch
Okay das Stück kostet
Auch noch 47 Cent
Meins war ein bisschen breiter
Aber
Guckt euch das an
Das sieht aus als hätte ich das zusammen gebastelt
Daheim
Wahrscheinlich mussten das auch irgendwie
Die Kinder im Keller zusammen löten
Oder so
Ein ganz großer Schrott
Preise zu nennen weil die sich eben
So oft verändern
Wenn man den Timo Smartwatch mit dem Handy verbunden hat
Dann stellt sich die Uhr automatisch
Als Bluetooth Kopfhörer ein
Und gibt auch Musik wieder
Und das ist jetzt erwartungsgemäß
Gar nicht mal so toll
Ach ne
Boah
Krasser Sound
Komax
Den jetzt auch nicht gerade den seriösesten Eindruck macht
Dann haben wir uns bei
Das ist gut dass du den Weg hierher gefunden hast
Weil auf Youtube habe ich ja in letzter Zeit recht wenig gemacht
Ich würde gerne übrigens ein Video zum Ende des Jahres machen
Sinngemäß
Tja sowas wie
Hat sich
Hat sich das gelohnt den Job zu wechseln
Und würde ich es wieder machen
Weil also ich bin mir noch nicht sicher wie der Titel wird
Weil
Ich habe das hier im Stream schon öfters gesehen
Dass Leute mit dem Gedanken spielen
Sich was neues zu suchen und für viele ist halt
Der 31.12.
So der Stichtag wo man
Was neues haben muss beziehungsweise kündigen muss
Wegen drei Monaten
Ja Kündigungs
War der neue Job ein Fehler
Ja das ist das ist ein guter
Ein guter Videotitel ja
Und dann ist
Ne totaler Reinfall das hatte ich schon
Das hatte ich schon
Und im Thumbnail dann
Jetzt
Neu bewerben
Aber ganz ehrlich
Ich will es eigentlich gar nicht so
Im Titel
Weil eigentlich geht es mir nicht darum so sehr
Über meine Sache jetzt
Konkret zu reden
Sondern einfach nur ob es sich gelohnt hat
Ob ich es
Also ob ich es nochmal wieder machen würde
Und was ich den Leuten
Empfehlen würde
Die jetzt
Auch in ähnlichen Situationen
Du hast das oder das als Emote gefunden
For the China
China Cat
Ja ich brauche aber für meine
Also
Oh je Leute
Das GIF ist etwas wenig
Transparent
Und außerdem viel zu wenig hoch aufgelöst
Ne das können wir nicht das muss weg
So Video fertig gucken
So was haben wir als nächstes jetzt
Installieren die jetzt auch nicht gerade
Den seriösesten Eindruck macht
Dann haben wir uns bei Temu noch diesen Beamer bestellt
Ach das ist ein Beamer
Ach deswegen so eine billige China Chinesen Kamera
Der jetzt bekannt vorkommen sollte
Ja der wird auf Social Media auch von diversen
Dropshipping Accounts intensiv
Mit teils absurden Versprechen beworben
Habt ihr den Text unten gelesen
100 Euro
Beamer um welchen besser ist
Als mein 100.000 Euro
Fernseher
Also das erste Ding ist
Warum zum Teufel
Hat der Dude einen 100.000 Euro
Fernseher
Dass das Preis leistungsmäßig shit ist
Da hätte ich ihm auch gleich
Sagen können
Dass der Beamer besser ist
Das glaube ich ihm trotzdem nicht
Verifiziert von MrBeast
Ja dann ganz sicher
Bei 12 Herzen und einem Bookmark
Chat
Was ist dieses Bookmark Icon
Was macht man damit
Diversen Dropshipping Accounts
Intensiv mit teils absurden Versprechen
Beworben
Wir haben dafür etwa 63 Euro bezahlt
Auf Amazon und in den Dropship Stores
Kostet der etwa 90
93 Bewertungen
Davon sind wahrscheinlich 80 China Chinesen
Fakt Bewertungen
Wenn ich mich jetzt festlegen müsste
Würde ich sagen das ist noch das Beste
Aus unserer TEMO Bestellung
Ich würde den aber auch wirklich niemanden
Ernsthaft empfehlen
In unserem Test konnten wir den zum Beispiel
Ja und der schützt bestimmt nur noch WEP
WLAN
Der kann bestimmt nichts neues
Also konnten wir auch die ganzen integrierten Streaming Dienste
Und das Android System darauf nicht nutzen
Aber nachdem wir dann Fire TV und eine Soundbar
Angeschlossen hatten ging das eigentlich ganz okay
Also wenn man jetzt nicht so hohe Erwartungen
An Farbechtheit und so hat
Dann kann man damit schon über den HDMI Anschluss was anschauen
Dafür war aber die Lautstärke
Des Lüfters mit 55 Dezibel
Deutlich lauter als die
Von TEMO versprochenen 25 Dezibel
25 Dezibel
Das ist nicht hörbar
25 Dezibel ist glaube ich
25 ist so krass wenig
Das ist so Herzschlag
Wenn du in der Nähe stehst
Oder so leise
Ja
Ruheräusche im TV Studio
Ist das
Ja ganz bestimmt
Also die Lüfter Lautstärke
Liegt angeblich Ruheräusche
Im Studio
Zwischen ruhiges Schlafzimmer bei Nacht
Und Ruheräusche im TV Studio
Da muss man die Boxen schon richtig auftreten
Dass man das nicht mehr hört
Die Angaben über die Bildqualität haben sich auch
Auf der Produktseite widersprochen
Mal wurde von HD dann von Ultra HD gesprochen
Laut Herstellerangaben
HDR kann er angeblich auch
Aber zumindest hat der Appie immer Inhalte an die Wand
Geworfen und grob das gehalten was er verspricht
Ein bisschen enttäuschender war
Dieses Mini Smartphone
Ja
Das sieht aus wie
So ein bisschen modernerer Kurzzeitwecker
Für die Küche
Ich finde das gut
Dass sie das mit den Händen machen
Ich würde das Ding auch nicht anfassen wollen
Da kriegst du bestimmt gleich Ausschlag
Wenn du das anfasst
Boah
Fünf Kameras
Das ist 100%
Das ist 100% einfach nur Fake
Da ist überhaupt kein Sensor dahinter
Aber auch wenn da hinten fünf Kameras
Angebracht zu sein scheinen
Von denen ist nur eine echt
Und das Gerät
Keine Ahnung
Die China-Chinesen
Aber gut
Für 25 Euro Smartphone
Ist auch S23 Pro
Ja und die ganze Performance
Ist nochmal eine ganze Ecke schlechter
Als so ein einfaches Einsteiger Android Smartphone
Also klar theoretisch funktioniert schon vieles
Man kann Apps installieren
Man kann Fotos machen
Aber alles super langsam
TikTok zum Beispiel ist quasi unbenutzbar
Browsen geht auch kaum
Das ist ja komplett für den Arsch
Gar nicht so leicht da Eingaben zu machen
Aber immerhin lügen sie nicht
Was die Android-Version angeht
Also wir haben da drin Android 8
Das ermöglicht aber immerhin Apps wie Signal zu verwenden
Die würden ja auf einem reinen Feature-Phone gar nicht laufen
Ja okay
Aber wenn man dann eine verschlüsselte Kommunikation
Verwenden möchte
Wobei du dann immer noch eine SIM-Karte brauchst
Wenn du unterwegs bist
Oder WLAN-Hackermans
Nee aber dann
Ansonsten
Das kann ja keiner wirklich sinnvoll
Gebrauchen für irgendwas
Auch so eine Spielerei
Ist dieser Spionagestift
Der nicht nur schreiben kann sondern auch Videos aufzeichnen
Der hat etwa 25 Euro gekostet
Und ja funktioniert und ist von der Qualität
Auch überraschend okay
Also ist natürlich creepy mit so einem Stift zu filmen
Und immer eine rechtliche Grauzone
Wenn ich komplett illegale Menschen ohne ihr Wissen mit Bild und Ton
Aufzeichnen will
Die Qualität für so eine Furzkamera
Im Stift geht doch halbwegs in Ordnung
Das ist irgendwie eine Auflösung
Von ja
700 x 500
Wobei das ist 16 zu 9
Das ist irgendwie
800 x 500 oder so
Von den Videos ist für den kleinen Sensor
Der da verbaut ist ganz okay
Ja so sieht das Video dann aus
Und dann haben wir noch diese Maske hier bestellt
Die kann sich mit dem Smartphone verbinden
Und dann verschiedene Designs anzeigen
Da kann man dann einfach ein Bild hochladen
But why?
Und die eingebauten LEDs
Zeigen das dann an
Hat alles soweit funktioniert
But why?
Und warum genau?
Also was macht man damit jetzt?
Wie bei Teemu angegeben
Das ist für die nächsten Hongkong Protester
Wahrscheinlich ganz gut
Diese elektrische Kettensäge
War dafür einfach
Komplett fake
Also elektrisch kann die sowieso nicht sein
Weil da kein Motor oder irgendwas elektrisches eingebaut ist
Aber ohnehin war uns überhaupt nicht klar
Wie das Ding funktionieren soll
Diese Anleitungen sind immer geil
Das ist bei vielem
Elektronischen Kram dabei
Die man bei China Seiten bestellt
Das sind so kleine
Selbst ausgedruckte
Handbücher dabei
Die oftmals nur aus einer kleinen Seite oder nur einer halben Seite
Teilweise noch zerknittert bestehen
Und man versteht überhaupt nicht
Was die von einem wollen
Electric Drill Stand
Selbst die Überschrift ergibt keinen Sinn
Ohnehin war uns überhaupt nicht klar
Wie das Ding funktionieren soll
Vielleicht fehlten auch einfach Teile
Aber in der Form wie wir das Ding bekommen haben
Und in den Müll werfen
Diese kleine Überwachungskamera war mit 3,48€ super billig
Konnte sich dafür
Ach vielleicht macht man das vorne
Auf eine Bohrmaschine drauf
Chat ihr seid high IQ heute
Das würde ich mich aber trotzdem nicht
Nicht trauen
Auch nicht mal auf einen Agguschrauber vorne drauf
Weil
Da ist ja wirklich Power dahinter
Und das Ding fliegt dir um die Ohren
Aber auch mit nichts verbinden
Was wir da so versucht haben
Ich würde leider auch nicht sagen
Ob die überhaupt irgendwas aufnimmt
Also auch hier muss man so eine App installieren
Die gerne Zugriff auf ungefähr alles hätte
Aber die hat sich nicht verbunden
Als wir bei Temo bestellt haben
War es noch ein paar Grad wärmer
Also haben wir auch diesen Nackenventilator
Für 14€
Ein Nackenventilator
Es gibt so viel Schrott auf diesen
China Seiten
Oh ausprobieren wollen
Ja okay da kommt Luft raus
Es ist nicht besonders angenehm
Lukas fand das offenbar auch nicht
Und das Ding ist auch ultra laut
Dieses kleine Pulsoximeter
Für 2,69€
Hat im Gegensatz zu den Smartwatches scheinbar
Wirklich was gemessen
Zumindest konnte er nicht mit einer Gummipuppe
Oder anderen hautähnlichen Gegenständen überlistet werden
Allerdings sind die meisten Messergebnisse falsch
Also hier die Blutsauerstoffsättigung
Von 86%
Das ist definitiv nicht richtig
Also ganz wichtig
Verlasst euch nicht auf irgendwelche Messergebnisse
Von Temo teilen
Mein Fazit
Temo ist ein fragwürdiges Unternehmen
Das unter fragwürdigen Bedingungen
Produzierte Dinge in fragwürdiger Qualität verkauft
So würde ich das jetzt mal zusammenfassen
Von allen Sachen die wir bestellt haben
Habe ich bei keiner einzigen Lust sie weiter zu benutzen
Dabei haben wir bei einigen Dingen extra
Nicht die aller billigste Variante auf Temo bestellt
Und dass man für etliche Produkte
Noch eine extra App installieren muss
Hinterlässt auch ein echt blödes Gefühl
Also von mir absolut keine Empfehlung
Tut euch was Gutes und bestellt da nicht
Bestellt einfach bei Aliexpress
Oder bei Banggood
Immer noch der beste Seitenname
Ihr es aus irgendwelchen Gründen trotzdem wollt
Dann benutzt die Website und nicht die App
Und ja, dass wir die Werbeanfrage von Temo
Nicht angenommen haben, das habt ihr euch sicher
Inzwischen schon selbst gedacht
Wir möchten kein Geld von Temo haben
Eine wichtige Frage bleibt noch
Spielt jemand von euch Modern Warfare 3
Jetzt wo ich es gerade sehe
Es geht mir voll am Arsch vorbei
Ich habe es nicht gekauft, wer es auch nicht kaufen
Schreibt gerne in die Kommentare
Und gerne auch eure Erfahrungen mit Temo
Falls ihr schon welche gemacht habt
Tschüss
Ja, der Shop
Heißt ernsthaft
Banggood
Wahrscheinlich weil du so viel
Ich weiß auch nicht warum der so heißt
Weil du viel Bang
Banggood kriegst oder so
Keine Ahnung warum Banggood so heißt
Aber es ist GG
Auf jeden Fall
GG Eats
Ah hier, Pipo Workout
Also ich finde Modern Warfare
Hat sich schlecht angefühlt
Taugt das?
Gucken wir jetzt nicht
Ich finde Herr der Ringe Spiele immer ganz nice
Wenn die taugen
Aber die meisten taugen ja nicht
Mehr Tabs habe ich doch hier
Hier haben wir noch ein paar Tabs
Was haben wir denn sonst hier noch zu bieten
Polish Amazon offers
Deals so good their servers implode
Ok, 8 Minuten
Der hat ein ganz gutes Video
Über den GitLab Ausfall gemacht
Gucken ob das auch taugt
Ob das auch taugt
2018 Allegro
The largest eCommerce platform in Poland
Known for feats such as creating a viral
3 Minute long Christmas advertisement
Ist das Text to speech?
Nein das ist kein Text to speech
Der hört sich immer so an
Aber ich finde er hört sich immer so an wie Text to speech
On July 18, 2018, Allegro
The largest eCommerce platform in Poland
Known for feats such as creating a viral
3 Minute long Christmas advertisement
Not being racist and the Allegro zone
Das sieht auch aus! Leute, guckt euch die Webseite an!
Ist das auch vom chinesischen Webdesign-Ministerium?
Die sieht ja genauso aus!
Das könnte Banggood, AliExpress, DHGate oder Temu sein!
Okay, es sieht ein bisschen mehr amazonisch aus.
Okay, aber ansonsten...
Very special limited time sale.
They were going to sell 100 Honor 7c phones
Whos regular price was about 200€ at the time
For a mere one polish unit of currency
This offer was scheduled to start at noon
And marketing material for the event has already been published
At 11.15, 45 minutes prior to the deal going live
The engineers knew that website traffic was going to spike
So they preemptively scaled out the listing service
To prepare for the onslaught
Das haben wir schon den ersten Fehler!
nicht diagonal skaliert. Wisst ihr, die hätten bei uns mal sich ein bisschen
Consulting-Kram einkaufen sollen. Da hätte ich denen gleich gesagt, wenn ihr das
nicht diagonal skaliert, dann ist das nix. Hyper-Scaled-Diagonal.
Ja.
Au!
Ja, das ist ja so ein Problem, Leute. Das kennt ihr bestimmt alle. Das muss ich euch
jetzt mal zeigen. Und das ist wirklich ein Problem für Services. Man glaubt es nicht,
aber das ist wirklich ein Problem. Und zwar, was macht ihr? Also mal angenommen, ihr geht
jetzt auf eine Webseite. Mal angenommen, ihr geht auf AliExpress. Wir nehmen jetzt mal
AliExpress, weil AliExpress ein gutes Beispiel dafür ist. AliExpress ist immer schön langsam.
So, also ihr seid jetzt auf AliExpress und ihr sucht auf AliExpress was. So. Ihr sucht
auf AliExpress was. So. Und ihr klickt jetzt. Oh man, AliExpress, Alter. Ihr klickt jetzt.
So, klick. Suche. Passiert nix. Was macht ihr als nächstes? So, also ihr klickt jetzt.
Suchen. Suchen. Und es passiert nix. Was macht ihr dann? Ihr drückt nochmal. Suchen. Suchen.
Suchen. Suchen. Suchen. Suchen. Suchen. Suchen. Suchen. Suchen. Suchen. Suchen. Suchen. Suchen.
Das heißt, das ist, genau, genau. Und das ist wirklich ein Problem für manche, je nachdem
wie das gemacht ist, für manche Frontends oder für manche Anbieter, dass sobald es ein
bisschen Load drauf kommt und es langsamer respondet, es nicht einfach nur linear so
weitergeht, langsamer respondet, sondern auf einmal eine Vielzahl der User anfängt zu
refreshen und es anstelle von, ja, es dauert jetzt halt pro Request statt 50 Millisekunden
250 Millisekunden, auf einmal jetzt zehnmal so viele Requests reinkommen, weil die Leute
alle denken, Alter, das kann doch nicht sein. Hier, refresh, refresh, refresh, refresh, refresh.
Der Browser kann das schon cachen, aber eine Get-Anfrage muss der initial trotzdem machen.
Alter, wenn die Seite nicht geladen ist, was soll er dann da cachen? Also, das ist wirklich
ein Problem. Und was, nochmal. Der Frontend-Service eventuell genau wegen dem, was ich gerade
gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt
habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist,
dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass
der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service
eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell
wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem,
was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe,
ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass
der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service
eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell
wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem,
was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe,
ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service
eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem,
was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe,
ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service
eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem,
was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass der Frontend-Service eventuell wegen dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe,
Sage ich doch. Sag ich doch. Die Leute haben... ach ne... die Seite hat Retry Requests geschickt.
Naja, das ist natürlich auch ein bisschen doof, wenn die die ganze Zeit.
Ja, ich bitte das. Die wollen das reloaden.
Problem ist, wenn die alle 5 Sekunden checken und das irgendwie 10.000 User aufhaben,
dann sind das halt auch schon ein paar Requests.
Das mich fasziniert.
Ja, genau das, was ich gesagt habe.
Das, da hatte ich auch schon öfters mal einen Spaß mit.
Das ist ein File.
Also ein File ist nur ein sequentielles Stream von Daten, das öffentlich sein kann, durchgeführt, gelesen, geschrieben und geschlossen werden kann.
Wie kann ein Linux-Prozessor ein File erreichen?
Nun, du machst den Systemanruf öffnen und es erhält einen Handler oder einen Filedeskriptor,
den der Prozessor benutzt, um das File zu erreichen.
Aber was genau ist dieser Filedeskriptor?
Eigentlich ist es unter Linux am Ende glaube ich sogar auch nur eine weitere Datei?
Irgendwo? Irgendeine Pipe?
Aber letztendlich kannst du das limiten, dass Prozesse nicht unendlich viele Filehandels aufmachen können.
Und wahrscheinlich haben die es ein bisschen zu niedrig gesetzt.
Block-Device.
Das nennt man dann Block-Device.
Aufs Block-Device kommt das File-System und je nachdem was es ist, hast du bei Ext4 noch sowas wie Inodes dazwischen.
Und daraus ergeben sich dann logisch Dateien.
Ja, siehste? Aber das mit Inodes ist glaube ich nur in der Ext4 so.
Es gibt keinen Weg, Open-File-Metadaten zu besorgen.
Files in Linux können auf verschiedenen Wegen geöffnet werden.
Wir sehen hier einen Flags-Parameter, das wichtigste ist der Access-Mode, der nötig ist.
Jeder Open-File-Handler muss auch die aktuelle Position im File beachten.
All dieses Metadata wird in einer anderen Datenstruktur besorgt, die einen Open-File bezeichnet.
Super-File-Fat, wie das unter der Haube funktioniert.
Chat, nachher gibt's ne Prüfung, na aufpassen.
Reicht ja normalerweise auch.
Ja, damit hatte ich auch schon sehr viele Schmerzen.
Gerade auf unseren alten HA-Proxy-Kisten, da gab es öfters mal Probleme.
Da mussten wir das auch hochsetzen.
Okay, zurück zum Hauptproblem.
Die Ingenieure fanden die Grundgründe für die unzählige Kapazität.
Andere Random-Services hatten viel mehr Ressourcen als notwendig,
also war ihr Cloud technisch aus der Kapazität, denn es war alles reserviert.
Reservierte Kapazität hier bedeutet virtuelle CPUs und Memory, die zu einem bestimmten Service eingestellt werden.
Obwohl Allegro ein privates Cloud-Umfeld benutzt, das sie auf der Bühne betreiben,
Das habe ich ja noch nie erlebt, also ich kenne das, aber ich habe es noch nie benutzt,
und ich habe nie erlebt, dass es jemand, ich kenne keinen, der Mesos benutzt.
Kennt ihr einen? Ich... Keine Ahnung.
Jetzt schon, ja.
Die Leute rasten ja immer, weil sie nicht wissen, was sie machen.
Das ist ja auch so.
Ja, die Leute rasten ja immer bei jedem Scheiß aus, ja.
Das ist doch mal nice, dass die sich da die Mühe gemacht haben, die Leute rauszusuchen, oder?
Ich meine, vielleicht haben sie einfach random Leute rausgepickt.
Das muss doch nicht mal sagen, ob es überhaupt die Top 100 waren.
Aber zumindest haben sie sich Mühe gegeben, das gerade zu biegen wieder.
Das finde ich nicht schlecht.
Finde ich nicht schlecht.
Also immerhin haben sie sich Mühe gegeben.
Das könnte man als Ultramilliardär nicht.
Einen Teil des Internets lahmlegen, indem man AWS-Ressourcen reserviert.
Er so lange nicht AWS-Ressourcen reservieren lässt.
AWS lässt sich ja nicht jetzt so viele Ressourcen reservieren, dass alles andere down geht, was da drauf schon läuft.
Also ich glaube, wenn du Milliardär bist und dir hilft und einen großen Teil des Internets lahmlegen möchtest,
dann hast du andere Möglichkeiten.
Das ist tatsächlich nicht ganz so einfach.
Zum Glück, muss man sagen, skalieren Loadbalancer sehr gut mit CPU-Anzahl.
Das heißt, Loadbalancer skaliert man wahrscheinlich am einfachsten vertikal anstelle von horizontal.
Du machst dir einfach fetter.
Fettere Netzwerkkarten, fettere CPUs, fetter alles.
Loadbalancer skalieren ziemlich gut, was das angeht.
Ansonsten, wenn das nicht geht, dann muss man sich Gedanken drüber machen,
ob man zum Beispiel das mit...
Oh, ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt.
Man kann, das habe ich einmal gemacht, das ist schon richtig lang her.
Man kann Loadbalancer random picken lassen anhand ihrer MAC-Adresse.
Ich kriege es überhaupt nicht mehr zusammen, wie das genau gewesen ist.
Also du kannst so eine relativ random Last-Verteilung erzeugen.
Was war das nochmal?
Chat, hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert?
Was ich meine, falls ihr versteht, was ich meine.
Ich habe komplett verdrängt, wie das heißt.
Nee, nee, nix Spanning-Tree.
Ich habe komplett vergessen, wie das heißt.
Das geht.
Du kannst bei Linux irgendwie einstellen,
dass sich bei Paketen, die reinkommen,
immer nur welche mit...
Also die kriegen dann ein Interface mit einer vorberechneten MAC-Adresse
und dann fühlen sich immer nur abwechselnd welche dafür angesprochen.
Du musst natürlich sicherstellen, dass das an alle zugesteht.
Ich habe...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das heißt ja einfach nur von eins nach dem anderen.
Da brauchst du wieder irgendwas davor.
Nee.
Ich krieg das nicht mehr zusammen.
Riecht wie Blödsinn.
Ich habe es komplett verdrängt, wie das heißt.
Wir haben damit mal rumexperimentiert.
Du konntest quasi an dem Switch einstellen,
dass der Traffic rausgeht.
An alle drei.
Und die MAC-Adressen von den Loadbalancer,
das war irgendwie so aufgebaut,
dass sich...
Oh, ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, wie das funktioniert.
Dass sich dann der eine nur für diese Sachen angesprochen gefühlt hat,
der eine nur für diesen einen,
sodass sich das verteilt hat auf mehrere Loadbalancer.
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, wie das heißt.
Ich habe kein Plastenschimmer mehr, wie das hieß.
Nee, mit BGP war das nix.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ich kann es euch nicht sagen.
Aber ansonsten ist Loadbalancer-Skalieren echt nicht so easy.
Ich habe da kein Pauschalrezept jetzt aus dem Kopf,
wie ich sagen würde, so skaliert man Loadbalancer.
Chat, wie skaliert ihr Loadbalancer?
Ich würde sagen, das einfachste Loadbalancer...
Es kann auch sein, dass ich in der Richtung...
Das einfachste Loadbalancer zu skalieren,
ist vertikal einfach fettere Kiste.
Ja, was das ist, weiß ich auch.
Aber das ist ja nicht die Erklärung, wie es technisch läuft.
Du musst...
Normalerweise hast du das Problem,
dein Loadbalancer...
Also, sagen wir mal ganz easy.
Du hast irgendeinen Webservice.
Das Ding hat eine externe Domain.
Das löst auf auf die IP von dem Loadbalancer.
Hinter der IP vom Loadbalancer
kann ja erst einmal nur eine Kiste stehen.
Zumindest so pauschal gesehen.
Unter der Haube
können das natürlich schon auf mehrere Kisten verteilt werden.
Was du machen kannst, ist
sowas wie Anycast.
Dass du den nächsten Node nimmst
zum...
den nächsten Node,
quasi den nächsten Eingang vom Kunde aus.
Das hilft dir aber nur,
wenn du weltweit gut aufgestellt bist.
Nachdem der Traffic Dark
komplett aus Polen
auf den polnischen Service kommt,
wird es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwieriger.
Du kannst DNS-Loadbalancing nehmen.
Das ist nicht verkehrt.
Also, DNS-Loadbalancing wäre tatsächlich
gar nicht so doof in dem Fall.
Bei ganz vielen...
Ja, genau. Das meine ich ja.
DNS-Loadbalancing wäre gar nicht so blöd
in dem Fall,
dass du bei der DNS-Auflösung
einfach mehrere IPs zurücklieferst
oder eben unterschiedliche IPs,
je nachdem, je nach Anfrage.
Das könnte man machen.
Das bringt ja auch nichts.
Da hast du wieder das Problem,
wie skalierst du diesen einen Loadbalancer?
Also das ist tatsächlich auch das naheliegendste,
was mir jetzt erst einmal einfällt.
So DNS-Loadbalancing
zu betreiben an der Stelle.
Mehrere Eingangs-IPs zu verteilen,
was dahinter steckt.
Mag nicht immer gehen.
Ich habe beim besten Willen keine Ahnung mehr,
wie das hieß mit diesen
MAC-Adressen.
Ich fühle mich angesprochen,
ich fühle mich nicht angesprochen.
So nach dem Motto Traffic.
Traffic kommt auf beiden an.
So ich fühle mich nur für gerade Pakete,
du nur für ungerade.
Das sagt mir...
Wie könnte man das abkürzen?
ESBLB?
Nee.
Kommt mir nicht bekannt vor.
Also das wäre auf jeden Fall mit Abstand
das einfachste DNS-Loadbalancing.
Oder DNS mehrere Records.
Oder eben den DNS-Server
unterschiedliche Sachen zurückgeben lassen.
Was du machen kannst ist,
du hast vier Loadbalancer,
die weiterleiten auf deine Backend-Services
und du gibst einfach mehrere Antworten
in deinem...
Das kann sein.
Ich kann mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Ich weiß nur, dass wir da vor Jahren
mal mit rumgebastelt haben.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Das kommt mir irgendwie schon bekannt davor.
Du gibst...
Also normalerweise,
wenn du einen DNS-Server anfragst,
gib mir die IP von Twitch,
dann antwortet der mit einem A-Record
und sagt hier,
Twitch hat diese IP.
Du kannst aber auch mehrere A-Records zurückgeben.
Am besten random verteilt.
Oder halt immer ein anderer.
Random verteilt,
sodass der Client eben halt
auf einen davon geht.
Da hast du schon mal sehr viel gewonnen dadurch.
Dann hast du aus einem Eingang
vier Eingänge gemacht
und das reicht dann in der Regel.
Oder zwei, oder drei, oder vier,
oder zehn, oder was auch immer.
Anycast Routing ist ganz gut,
wenn du mehrere Standorte hast, ja.
Da weiß ich nicht,
was ChatGPT genau damit sagen will.
Das ergibt auch keinen Sinn.
Das ergibt jetzt auch
für Loadbalancing selbst
nicht so viel Sinn.
Und ja, gut,
für Frontend-Sachen ausliefern.
Nee, aber wenn's random ist,
ist es trotzdem jeder ungefähr gleich viel.
Das ist sicherlich,
wenn man das machen kann,
sicherlich das einfachste.
Ja, du musst mir keine
ChatGPT-Antwort reinkopieren.
VRRP kommt mir bekannt vor
in dem Zusammenhang.
Nee, das bringt dir ja nix.
Das ist nur für Failover.
Naja.
Gibt es einen Unterschied
zwischen Loadbalancer und Reverse-Proxy?
Ja, gibt es.
Es hat sehr viele Überschneidungen.
Loadbalancer heißt ja im Prinzip
erstmal nur,
unabhängig vom Protokoll,
dass du
Pakete bekommst
und die auf mehrere Ziele aufteilst.
Reverse-Proxy
bedeutet ja,
dass der Server,
wo du drüber gehst,
mit dem Protokoll was anfangen kann.
Ja, zum Beispiel
ein Webserver,
also ein Reverse-Proxy
vor irgendeinem HTTP-Endpunkt,
der kann zum Beispiel auch
SSL-Terminierungen machen
und solche Geschichten,
weil der so ungefähr checkt,
was dort passiert.
Ein stinknormaler Loadbalancer
kann beispielsweise
auf Layer 3
TCP-Sachen durchleiten
oder UDP-Sachen durchleiten.
Also Proxy kann man eigentlich
immer sagen,
versteht so ungefähr,
was da drüber geht.
Kann eventuell auch
anhand des Traffics
spezielle Sachen machen, ja.
Zum Beispiel ein Reverse-Proxy,
dem kannst du ja auch sagen,
nicht nur Port rein,
Port raus,
sondern den kannst du auch sagen,
Request-Proxy.
Den kannst du auch sagen,
Request-Fahrt,
da und dahin, dahin.
Oder dieser Host,
ja, so funktioniert das ja
bei beispielsweise
HTTP-Reverse-Proxys.
Wenn dieser Host
drinnen steht,
in dem HTTP-Request,
dann auf dieses Ziel.
Das kann ein normaler
Loadbalancer nicht.
Ein normaler Loadbalancer
kann nur sagen,
ey,
Verbindungsaufbau,
SYN-Package kommt an,
dahin weiter.
Und was ein
TCP-Loadbalancer auch noch
können sollte,
ist Sticky-Sessions,
dass eine
aufgebaute
TCP-Verbindung
immer zum gleichen
Endpunkt geht,
weil ansonsten kriegst du
Probleme mit
TCP-Verbindung.
Aber ein
reiner Loadbalancer
ist halt viel dümmer,
der schickt wirklich
einfach nur weiter
und Reverse-Proxy kann mit
dem Inhalt was anfangen.
Aber es hat sehr große
Überschneidung,
auf jeden Fall,
wie das benutzt wird.
Ja, so läuft es
in der Regel dann auch, ja.
Du machst beispielsweise
auf so einem
Reverse-Proxy,
dann,
du hast einen
Web-Service,
Reverse-Proxy davor,
der macht dann meistens auch
SSL-Terminierung.
Also SSL-Terminierung
heißt,
der hat dann
ein Let's Encrypt-Zertifikat,
nimmt den Traffic an
und schickt den weiter
an den eigentlichen
Web-Server,
allerdings dann,
so wie es hier
Darkzone geschrieben hat,
nur über HTTP.
Ja, richtig.
Aber wie gesagt,
das ist alles
ein bisschen schwammig.
HA-Proxy
beispielsweise,
der ja eigentlich als
ja,
HTTP-Loadbalancer
mal angefangen hat
oder als Web-Loadbalancer,
kann auch Layer 3
Loadbalancing.
Wenn man beides
verwendet,
was kommt,
das kommt ein bisschen
drauf an,
was man machen will.
Das kommt ein bisschen,
ganz ehrlich,
bei Web-Services
ist das meistens
in einer,
in einer Sache drin.
Also in der Regel
würde ich eigentlich sagen,
einfacher dürfte es sein,
also je nach Service,
erst über den Proxy
zu gehen,
SSL-Terminierung zu machen,
dann auf den Loadbalancer
und das verteilen.
Allerdings,
wie gesagt,
der Proxy
kann auch
Loadbalancen
auf die Endpoints.
Also insofern,
je nachdem,
was man machen will,
ja,
je nachdem,
was man machen will.
Wenn,
wenn du ganz
super viel Traffic
verteilen musst
auf verschiedene Proxys
sogar,
weil das nicht reicht,
dann muss dann halt
ein fetter Loadbalancer
davor
oder mehrere
Eingangs-Loadbalancer
davor.
Also man kann auch
die Loadbalancer
davor stellen.
Es ist,
ey,
kommt drauf an,
ähm,
naja,
ja,
schon,
aber irgendwo
muss ja
die ganze
SSL-Geschichte passieren.
Also an irgendeiner Stelle
musst du es machen
und ja,
natürlich ist das
langsamer,
dadurch,
dass der mehr macht,
ja,
aber der kann halt auch mehr.
Weil ansonsten,
wenn du es einfach
nur Loadbalancen,
müsstest du auf jedem
Backend-Service
ein gültiges
SSL-Zertifikat haben,
was
sehr wahrscheinlich
nicht der Fall ist.
Was muss euch
ein Büroarbeiter
bieten?
Ich brauche keinen
Obstkorb.
Also ich hätte gerne Ruhe,
Ruhe,
einen höhenverstellbaren
Schreibtisch,
einen ordentlichen
Stuhl
und,
äh, ja,
vielleicht ein bisschen
Möglichkeit,
Wasser zu holen
in der Nähe.
Das war es aber auch.
Ich habe bei mir
vor Ort auf der Arbeit
alles,
zu dem einen Tag
die Woche,
wo ich aktuell da bin.
Nur der Stuhl
ist nicht so geil.
Haben wir noch irgendwas?
Leute,
ich habe übelst Hunger,
man!
Wir bauen den
Auer.
Was baut er denn?
Und wo ist die Katz?
Da ist die Katz.
Das ist ja auch
ein feiner,
dicker,
dicke Wurst.
Der ist niedlich.
Oder die?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Die ist deutlich
größer als meine.
Meine ist zwar auch
so ein bisschen wuschelig,
aber,
aber total klein.
Wupp,
wupp,
pet.
Ich muss mit
meiner Katze übrigens,
ähm,
am Montag,
äh,
die Katze
um die Uhr
am Montag
mal zum Tierarzt,
weil,
ähm,
also meine Katze
hat ja,
die ist ja schon älter,
die ist glaube ich jetzt zwölf
oder so.
Ich habe noch nie
halbtags gearbeitet.
Die ist zwölf
und die braucht
Nierenfutter,
weil die hat
ähm,
bisschen,
bisschen Nierenprobleme
und so.
Viele alte Katzen
haben,
haben Probleme
mit ihrer Nierenfunktion.
Die braucht
Nierendietfutter
und die kriegt,
ähm,
zweimal am Tag
so,
Phosphatbinder.
Das ist,
das,
das gibt man aus so einer Spritze
und
das ist das,
dass die Niere
nicht so viel arbeiten muss
und
der richtige Boomer Cat,
genau.
Und
ich habe jetzt gesehen,
die hat ein bisschen Blut
im Auge gehabt
gestern Abend
und Blut im Auge
deutet bei Katzen
immer ein bisschen
auf Bluthochdruck hin.
Bei Katzen geht das immer,
geht das wohl sehr schnell
auf die Augen
und da muss man aufpassen.
Das kann,
kann sich auf die,
auf die Augen
selbst
nur ganz kleines bisschen
am Rand.
Vielleicht hat sie sich,
vielleicht ist sie auch trocken
oder so.
Aber ich würde,
würde gerne mal,
dass der Tierarzt Blutdruck misst
bei meiner Katz.
Was mich auch ein bisschen stört,
dass, dass,
ich war jetzt schon zweimal
mit der Katze da
die letzten paar Monate,
dass die nicht selbst
auf die Idee gekommen sind,
weil
ich habe im Internet gelesen,
Katzen,
die Nierenprobleme haben,
neigen auch
zu zwei Drittel,
zwei Drittel der Katzen
oder bis zu zwei Drittel der Katzen
mit Nierenproblemen
haben
auch Bluthochdruck.
Und Bluthochdruck
sorgt dafür,
dass es eventuell
noch andere Organe
und die Niere
auch weiter schädigt.
Und bei Katzen
geht das sehr schnell
auf die Augen,
so dass es auch
sich auf die Hornhaut auswirkt
und dann,
dann sehen die schlechter
und sowas,
dann auch alles Kacke.
Man kriegt,
also ich meine,
Chico kriegt eh schon
zweimal am Tag Medikamente,
da kann die auch ein bisschen
Blutdruckmittel bekommen.
Aber dafür
müssen die das erstmal feststellen.
Wenn die wirklich Bluthochdruck hat,
werde ich die mal fragen,
warum die nicht schon früher
Blutdruck gemessen haben.
Wenn es doch eigentlich
normal ist
oder oft,
sehr oft vorkommt,
dass Katzen mit Nierenprobleme
schon öfters Bluthochdruck haben.
Ich meine,
da erwarte ich eigentlich nicht,
dass ich im Internet gucken muss,
sondern,
dass der Tierarzt
das selbst vorschlägt.
Kannst du ihr nicht
eine Temu Smartwatch holen?
Ja, genau.
Das bringt's bestimmt.
Ich glaube,
meine Smartwatch
kann keine,
kann keine Katzen auslesen.
Zumal du nur den Puls
und nicht den Blutdruck
erkennen kannst.
Übrigens wisst,
übrigens wisst ihr,
wo Katzen am Blutdruck
bekommen?
Am Schwanz
kriegen die Blutdruck gemessen,
oftmals.
Da kriegst du so eine Manschette
um den Schwanz unten
und dann wird dann aufgepumpt.
Ja,
man kann es auch an den Beinen machen,
aber es wird oftmals am Schwanz gemacht,
weil das die Katzen
wohl am besten mitmachen.
Kriegen dann so eine Manschette
am Schwanz
und wird aufgepumpt.
Sieht aus wie
ein bisschen kleiner,
aber im Prinzip
ist es wie bei Menschen,
Blutdruck messen.
Allerdings,
bei Katzen musst du es
ein paar Mal wiederholen,
weil die sind ja immer
so aufgeregt.
Deswegen,
deswegen würde ich gerne mal
einen Tierarzt heimbestellen.
Es gibt bei uns hier in der Nähe
so ein paar Tierärzte,
die bieten so ein Service an,
dass die quasi mit so einem
Tierarztauto
vorbeikommen
und da können die das
Blutdruckmessgerät nehmen,
weil Chico ist immer so,
die macht das gerne,
also nein,
die macht das nicht gerne,
aber das ist ja nicht so,
dass sie super Probleme hat
zum Tierarzt zu fahren,
das Auto fahren mag sie nicht,
aber gerade,
dass die entspannter ist
und zum Blutdruckmessen
ist ja sinnvoll,
wenn die entspannt ist,
dann sollen die mal vorbeikommen.
So sieht es aus.
Nun gut,
Chat,
ich bin gerade ganz stark
am überlegen,
ob wir noch was gucken
oder ob ich mir jetzt
was zu essen machen gehe.
Ich tendiere dazu,
ich gehe mir was zu essen machen,
weil ich massive Pepo-Fett-Hunger hab.
Nudel mit Lachs,
richtig,
Nudel mit Lachs gibt es,
ja, korrekt.
Wie kommt ihr da nur drauf?
Wie kommt ihr da drauf,
dass es Nudel mit Lachs gibt, man?
Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Woher wisst ihr das immer?
Ich gebe zu,
es ist bei mir nicht sonderlich kompliziert,
zu wissen,
was es sonntags zu essen gibt.
Alles klar.
Okay, Chat,
vielleicht heute Abend
noch eine Runde streamen,
aber wir müssen ein bisschen
was basteln wieder.
Ich wollte was in Go bauen
oder ich wollte ein bisschen
meine Go-Skills updaten,
was Go-Multithreading und Generics angeht.
Vielleicht probieren wir das heute Abend mal aus,
weil ich habe in letzter Zeit
vermehrt mal Sachen in Go
mir angeguckt
und gemacht.
Deswegen dachte ich mir,
oh nee, Dart,
Dart haben wir schon einmal gemacht,
da hält sich mein Bock drauf hin.
Rust habe ich auch keinen Bock,
Rust ist einfach nur super eklig zu schreiben,
hat aber seine Vorzüge in manchen Bereichen.
Ich gehe jetzt was fressen, Leute.
Wir sehen uns, bis denn.
Macht's gut,
tschüss.
Nee.
Bis denn.